et bonjour à tous Bienvenue les amis de
twitch on est sur la chaîne de Gautier
Geo spoil et on va se retrouver pour ce
premier épisode des Brest de spolium
alors vous avez dû remarquer si vous
suivez déjà la chaîne que je suis pas
Gauthier geost ou alors j'ai vraiment
fait une grosse chirurgie esthétique
mais c'est pas le cas moi peut-être que
vous me connaissez parce qu'on a fait
quelques live ensemble je m'appelle zoo
ou Guillaume pour les intimes
je vais présenter un peu les gens autour
de ma table du coup effectivement on est
sur la chaîne de côté donc on va
introduire tout de suite ce bon vieux
Gauthier bonjour bienvenue comment tu
vas ben ça va écoute merci de me
recevoir sur ma chaîne c'est oui
est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour les
gens qui viendraient des communautés de
nos autres invités et qui te
connaîtraient pas oui ben je m'appelle
Gauthier je suis vidéaste et médiateur
scientifique avec une petite un petit
attrait pour la géologie les sciences de
l'environnement
mais voilà on est en 2023 on se ferme
pas de porte donc j'ai pas la zone de
pas parler d'autre chose aussi
il y a des commandes pour aller voir les
réseaux sociaux de tous nos invités donc
branche je les ai oubliés parce que je
les ai pas noté
point d'exclamation Fredo ou point
d'exclamation je le spoil voilà comme
vous voulez aller voir son travail
n'hésitez pas dans le chat vous faites
un point d'exclamation Fredo ou point
d'exclamation géo spoil ça vous met un
petit lien vers ces réseaux et vous
pourrez aller voir abonnez-vous il fait
un travail sympathique c'est vrai
deuxième invité qu'on a autour de la
table Valentine les sciences de comptoir
bonjour Comment ça va bonjour
ça a l'air d'aller
bonjour ok bah écoute est-ce que tu peux
te présenter du coup pareil pour les
gens qui te connaîtraient pas et qui
viendraient des communautés des autres
je suis Valentine je fais plein de bruit
parasites et je parle aussi de géologie
c'est aussi mon travail et voilà et donc
sur la chaîne Youtube science de
comptoir
passer sauvage ou mais je sais pas ce
que c'est ça
en fait tu tapes
un point d'exclamation avec quelque
chose et c'est une commande qui en fait
affiche quelque chose
il va avoir une description de ton
personnage que tu vas jouer et un lien
vers ta chaîne Youtube ah et bien point
d'exclamation Gloria
et donc le dernier invité mais pas des
moindres Arnaud de stupide économique
bonsoir Comment ça va mais très bien
très bien prêt après pour l'aventure
est-ce que tu peux te présenter du coup
pareil que eh ben Arnaud de stupidité
donc c'est une chaîne de journaliste
économique on parle de
sujets parfois un peu lourds entre le
faut le dire voilà
c'est pas forcément tout le temps
marrant mais bon des fois on essaie de
le faire avec un petit peu de légèreté
pas toujours c'est pas c'est pas une
promesse et du coup
ma stupide économics donc j'imagine
pareil avec un petit point d'exclamation
avant
ou Pierre Alain voilà
comme vous voulez mettez ce que vous
voulez vous verrez bien ce qui va tomber
un modo ça marche vraiment pas qu'il y a
des gens qui vont veiller dans le chat
et vous donner les réponses sans
problème
on remercie du coup le CNC qui finance
cette émission en partie en grande
partie et
le quai des savoirs
entre autres ce magnifique studio dans
lequel on se trouve c'est vraiment
magnifique merci à eux ça aurait été pas
la même concrètement
alors vous avez dû voir par exemple que
Valentin Clotilde n'était pas forcément
super à l'aise avec le sujet
il s'avère que on a des débutants autour
de la table qui n'ont jamais fait de jeu
de rôle soyez indulgent
c'est normal c'est des gens qui sont
adorables qui vont apprendre donc c'est
pas un problème si jamais il y a des
questions qui reviennent des
incompréhensions etc ça va s'estomper
avec le temps et puis surtout notre
professionnalisme prendra le dessus ça
je pense qu'il y a pas de problème
masque vous dans le chat vous allez
aussi pouvoir jouer avec nous en
influant via des sondages et des quiz
donc parfois vous aurez une petite
alerte en haut qui vous dira il y a un
sondage où il y a un quiz qui est en
cours et vous verrez dans le chat vous
aurez des questions ou alors des
suggestions de qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que nous aventuriers fasse
donc simplement vous répondez et voilà
dans le cas d'un sondage le le choix qui
aura remporter se passera un peu plus
tard dans l'aventure dans le cas d'un
quiz si la majorité répond la bonne
question vous aurez le droit d'imposer
un bonus ou un malus à nos héros sur
leur prochaine action si jamais vous
vous trompez tous ensemble tant pis vous
n'aurez pas le droit d'influer
sur sur tout le monde
voilà voilà à la fin de l'émission On va
se réserver un petit 30 minutes pour
revenir un peu sur les sur tous les
aspects scientifiques qu'on aurait pu
aborder pendant le pendant les deux
heures trente de d'aventures préalable
le but ça va être de débloquer les
bêtises qui auraient été dit revenir sur
des sujets qui tiennent à cœur à
certaines personnes ou qui ont été un
peu trop élagués
c'est pas le mot que je voulais dire ça
aurait été vu un peu trop rapidement
voilà vous avez compris ce que je
voulais dire
vous pouvez réagir dans le chat il y a
les modérateurs qui vont nous faire
passer tous les messages ce sera avec
grand plaisir et à la fin de l'émission
on ouvrira les chats comme ça on pourra
répondre à vos questions directement ou
alors vous pouvez directement les poser
sur Twitter avec le
hashtagrofs
voilà comme ça on pourra venir vous voir
plus facilement peut-être sur Twitter
que si jamais il y a trop de gens qui
parlent dans le chat ça risque d'être
compliqué de choper vos questions à la
fin
voilà voilà bon écoutez est-ce que vous
voulez revenir sur un petit point là
avant qu'on lance où on peut y aller moi
je suis prêt
[Musique]
notre histoire se déroule dans la
province d'horizon une ville très
récente qui a été créée en tant que
ville pilote pour un nouveau
fonctionnement institutionnel pour
pouvoir atteindre rapidement ses
objectifs la ville reçoit de très
grandes subventions de la part de l'État
ce qui lui permet de se développer
extrêmement vite en sautant de
nombreuses étapes
on pourrait décrire horizon comme une
utopie les différentes rues sont très
bien entretenues avec de nombreux
espaces verts disséminés aux quatre
coins de la ville les véhicules
motorisés ne sont pas autorisés à
l'exception des transports en commun qui
ont été réfléchis pour les servir très
facilement n'importe quel point de la
ville
les objectifs principaux d'horizon sont
de réduire les écarts entre les
différentes classes sociales et
optimiser au maximum les émissions de
CO2 de manière à servir de modèle au
développement d'autres villes ou au
contraire de démontrer l'inefficacité
d'un tel modèle de fonctionnement
c'est dans ce contexte qui a été créé le
complexe scientifique Elixia en
périphérie d'horizon un complexe qui
regroupe quasiment toutes les catégories
de sciences existantes et qui propose de
nombreux cours sur ces dernières son
objectif faire avancer la science et
l'éducation au maximum dans le but de
développer encore plus la ville des
accords commerciaux existent donc entre
le complexe et horizon en effet
n'importe qui peut déposer un dossier
pour faire des recherches à Elixir sans
prérequis de formation
mais le potentiels inventions qui ont
résulte doivent être proposées à horizon
en priorité à tarif préférentiel
églantine bidon fameuse start-up puzz
originaire de la région ajustement
développé un nouveau système qui permet
de découvrir des gisements de pétrole au
sein du complexe elle s'est ensuite basé
sur ses recherches pour fonder sa
start-up Flappy néanmoins une de ses
affaires ne lui a pas été remise lors de
son départ et elle compte bien récupérer
ses biens
[Musique]
voilà et donc je suis très heureuse
d'être incubée au sein du complexe
Elixia alors ton incubation elle est
terminée du coup donc ça fait d'avoir
été un cubé
et là tu reviens au complexe parce que
tu dis que tu as oublié tes affaires oui
c'est faux mais tu as envie de venir
piquer des trucs en gros c'est pour ça
que j'ai une valise très grande et très
vide
du complexe Elixia il y a Marilyn Alma
qui est tu la connais parce que tu as
déjà travaillé à l'horizon c'est l'agent
d'accueil
bonjour églantine comment ça va salut
Maryline ça va super et toi ça va
tranquille qu'est-ce que je peux faire
ton petit
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour toi et
ben écoute j'ai oublié un petit truc
c'est vraiment idiot mais j'ai oublié un
petit truc tu sais au 14e et j'aimerais
bien juste passer le récupérer comme ça
tu peux m'ouvrir ok
juste en bas à gauche là et en fait
ouais c'est une sous section parce que 1
+ 4 ça fait 5
tu as oublié quelque chose je peux pas
lancer un défi
j'ai oublié juste mon
fer à lisser
mais si tu pouvais juste m'ouvrir la
porte merci
du coup elle te dit ah ok je vois je
vois tu étais ça doit être stocké en
salle à 4S du coup vu que tu étais dans
le 4e secteur je suppose elle appelle
quelqu'un sur son biper un certain tome
qui arrive qui est juste un agent
d'entretien et qui a du coup le passe
partout et elle lui demande de t'amener
là-bas et de t'ouvrir la salle pour que
tu puisses récupérer tes affaires
tranquillement merci Marylou tu es
adorable pas de souci
tu pars avec Tom tu prends un espèce de
petite ascenseur qui descend au sous-sol
parce qu'en fait il y a un mini métro
qui se balade de secteur en secteur du
coup tu prends le mini métro vers le
secteur 4
pendant ce temps
Gloria cupros oui tu es dans le complexe
scientifique édicien dans le troisième
secteur dans une salle est-ce que tu
peux te présenter ton personnage pour
les spectateurs et pour les gens autour
de la table oui alors je suis Miss
Gloria couper
je suis donc archéologue aujourd'hui
directrice du chantier de fouilles qui a
donc lieu sur un chantier qui vise à
construire une centrale
géothermique et évidemment voilà au
début du chantier sont apparus des
vestiges et là moi j'ai dit stop on
arrête tout
on réfléchit on s'arrête
voilà et là j'en suis là bon il y a
quelques
il y a un peu il y a un certain temps de
fouilles là qui qui est nécessaire
du coup tu as effectivement trouvé ces
vestiges et récemment sur les premières
fouilles vous avez réussi à trouver un
espèce de papier qui est très abîmé mais
étrangement bien conservé pour l'âge
es-tu justement au complexe scientifique
Elixia pour essayer de voir s'il y a pas
moyen de le restaurer donc tu as une
petite équipe de scientifiques qui est
dirigée par Sophie Lambert qui est une
scientifique qui travaille du coup dans
le secteur 3 mais malheureusement c'est
pas des gens qui ont été formés un
restaurer ce genre de choses du coup tu
vas devoir les leader donc ce que tu
peux nous expliquer comment au restau du
papier qui serait abîmé par la pluie et
la terre entre groguit mais alors il se
trouve que les conditions climatiques de
notre secteur sont assez favorables il
fait très humide là où nous sommes
heureusement le papier c'est comme la
peau ça ça fait des rides très vite donc
il faut de l'eau de l'eau de l'eau de
l'eau de l'acide hyaluronique ce genre
de choses quoi donc c'est sûr que là
avec cette équipe je les lâche pas je
les drive comme on dit maintenant
écoutez nous avons des machines qui nous
permettent de si vous voulez de stopper
l'aggravation la détérioration du papier
ce qui est perdu et perdu l'archéologie
c'est un deuil permanent donc par
exemple si on a une feuille de papier
qui serait recouvert de terre ce n'est
pas possible de
terre
qui recoud parce que la terre protège
d'accord oui notre plus grand ennemi
pour l'archéologie c'est l'air donc
l'air c'est la poussière l'air c'est la
mort
et du coup qu'est-ce que c'est une comme
méthode pour je suppose que la terre ça
protège mais on peut l'enlever pour voir
ce qu'il y a en dessous quand même on
l'enlève on l'enlève mais il faut
absolument que le papier reste dans un
lieu
anaérobic sans air donc là c'est tout un
protocole ou bien on va extraire ce
papier nous avons procédé par on a
enlevé la motte on a gardé la la Gange
je dirais de de terre tout autour et on
va l'étudier une fois qu'il sera dans un
espace sans air car encore une fois
l'air c'est la mort d'accord
du coup il suivent un peu tes
instructions donc il y a eu une
installation d'un bloc pour avoir un
espace scénarie tout à fait et du coup
vous avez réussi à enlever la terre qui
avait et vous vous retrouvez avec un
papier qui est néanmoins extrêmement
abîmé mais peut-être que il y aura quand
même des informations à en tirer mais le
temps le temps le dira je te le fais
passer
vous le voyez aussi chez vous sur le
live
pour si jamais vous le regardez en
podcast c'est un document une sorte de
parchemin ou l'encre ou écoulé
extrêmement abîmé très difficile à
déchiffrer c'est très intéressant
du coup Sophie Lambert elle te dit bon
ben maintenant qu'on le restaurer je
suppose qu'il va falloir qu'on l'a qu'on
le garde ah bah oui donc ce serait il
faudrait le mettre dans quoi comme
container pour s'assurer qu'il se
dégrade pas partir de maintenant
et ben on va sans doute le mettre dans
un dans un coffret avec encore une fois
une hygrométrie parfaitement contrôlée
pas qu'ils variation donc hygrométrie
c'est la quantité d'humidité dans l'air
si si je ne dis pas de bêtises
donc ça Sophie Lambert et c'est très
très bien faire j'ai tout confiance en
elle
et ensuite il faut surtout qu'on sache
ce que ça signifie le sens de cette ça
paraît comme une tâche pour pour
tout un chacun mais il y a tout un récit
il y a peut-être un ancrage mythologique
là-dedans et il faut qu'on trouve
très bien du coup elle te dit ah bah
justement ce genre de
ce genre de coffrit on en a en salle de
stockage A4s est-ce que c'est possible
que vous alliez en récupérer un parce
que moi je sais pas trop à quoi ça
ressemble d'accord mais je sais qu'on en
a
du coup c'est ce que tu es d'accord
d'aller en récupérer
un collègue il va vous accompagner et
tout elle appelle sur son biper du coup
elle appelle un certain Frédéric
donc ça sonne
Frédéric et oui allô je te dérange bon
écoute dis-moi est-ce que tu pourrais
accompagner madame Kuros en salle à 80
ok j'arrive elle est où là on est en
salle trois à 232 à 32 à 4 s ok j'arrive
pas j'arrive de suite donc tu arrives
donc il y a une pince qui s'ouvre et
vous vous rencontrez pour la première
fois bonjour mon petit frère
[Rires]
est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour nos
spectateurs et pour les autres autour de
la table oui mais moi je suis Fredo
Frédéric petit mais bon on peut
m'appeler Fredo je suis conscien je
complexe élixir et voilà je j'aime la
vie je suis bon vivant j'aime la viande
j'aime tout ça quoi
voilà ok donc vous vous rendez vers la
salle A4s donc tu sais que tu es dans le
secteur 3 c'est le secteur juste à côté
du coup tu te dis on va peut-être pas
prendre le métro
peut marcher je préfère parce que
il faut il faut rester mobile du coup
vous vous rendez vers le vers le secteur
4 donc là où il y a la salle A4s
et en fait entre chaque secteur il y a
une sorte de lobby avec une salle de
repos des petits distributeurs de snack
etc et du coup les entrées pour le métro
qui sont des espèces d'ascenseur et au
moment où tu arrives dans le lobby entre
le secteur 3 et le secteur 4 l'ascenseur
s'ouvre et tu croises ton ami Tom avec
une femme que tu ne connais pas
j'accompagne madame cupros qui vient
chercher un bac hermétique pour une
servi le papier tu vois où A4s ah mais
moi aussi et on y va
4S
tu veux pas t'en occuper et moi je vais
me fumer le garrot allez petit coquins
j'ai tempéré
vous vous rendez tous les trois vers la
sole A4s pendant ce temps
devant le complexe Elixia monsieur
Pierre-Alain Chicheportiche arrive
et va rentrer est-ce que tu peux te
présenter pour nos spectateurs et pour
les autres autour de la table et bien
Pierre Alain je suis sportif pachich
pour les plus vite si vous avez du mal à
dire mon nom de famille alors je suis
président de CCI et humaniste ça va de
soi
bon ma priorité forcément c'est le
développement économique de la ville
le tissu économique les artistes dans
les entreprises tout tout ce terreau
vivant qui vraiment fait l'accumulité de
vie de horizon et donc j'espère avec mon
travail au quotidien voilà de développer
cette cette magnifique ville il va faire
prospérer
voilà tout simplement très bien du coup
tu rentres dans le complexe initial tu
es venu en véhicule ce que tu as
quelques passes droits en tant que
président en tant qu'humaniste bien sûr
tu arrives et tu as rendez-vous si tu te
rappelles bien de ton background mais
oui avec quelqu'un tu es arrivé 20
minutes en avance comme comme d'habitude
mais tu te doutes que vu les
circonstances qui ont mené à ce
rendez-vous j'espère que tu te rappelles
un petit peu étrange tu as peur d'avoir
la moindre minute de retard donc tu as
envie d'arriver avant l'heure du
rendez-vous parce que tu sais pas
vraiment ce qui va se passer mais tu te
doutes qui va se passer quelque chose
c'est pas un rendez-vous ou normal c'est
plutôt pas rare donc tu es devant
l'entrée donc est-ce que tu rentres et
si tu bah je suis là pour rentrer alors
je rends très bien donc tu vois
l'hôtesse d'accueil qui s'appelle
Marilyn Alma qu'est-ce que tu vas la
voir
tout à fait oh monsieur J'ai sportif je
ne vous attendais pas alors sourire
bonjour Marilyn comment vous allez ah
mais très bien merci mais qu'est-ce que
vous faites ici et bien je suis venu
pour un rendez-vous figurez-vous un
rendez-vous et le feuillette est un peu
ce truc mais j'ai pas on n'a pas prévenu
alors un monsieur petit monsieur petit
Frédéric Frédéric petit rendez-vous avec
Frédéric petit rendez-vous d'une plus
grande importance je dois vous dire
d'accord du coup bon bah écoutez on m'a
pas prévenu mais je peux je vous assure
je peux peut-être l'appeler ah mais s'il
vous plaît oui donc ton téléphone sonne
ouais Fredo oui dis-moi est-ce que tu
avais un rendez-vous avec un avec
Monsieur Chicheportiche de quoi chichou
quoi Monsieur chiche sportif
on t'a pas prévu non plus bah non c'est
qui ce monsieur qui me veut c'est le
président de la CCI d'horizon tu as pas
entendu parler de la c'est quoi moi
j'ai pas de rendez-vous en tout cas ça
je peux te le dire
non plus
c'est pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il veut
un rendez-vous d'ordre business vraiment
c'est voilà très important et c'est
d'ordre business tu peux te rendre
disponible bientôt bah écoute oui enfin
le jeu là j'accompagne j'accompagne les
personnes récupérer les affaires
oui après oui t'es vers où là là je suis
je rentre à peine dans le secteur 4 là
je vais à 4S ok bon bah au pire revient
à l'accueil et tu feras ce rendez-vous
dans la foulée du coup je pense que je
vais accomp
et voilà donc je me dirige vers vers des
petits bancs
parce que tu dois le retrouver dans
moins de 20 minutes
c'est ça oui mais je je j'ai mon plan à
moi je vais donc tu vas vers des petits
bancs
bah j'attends que Marilyn regarde un
petit peu de l'autre côté et puis là
dernière très naturel je marche comme si
je savais où j'allais mais je sais où je
vais puisque j'ai construit le complexe
donc voilà et je marche dans la
direction où je sais que ok le secteur
4S tu marches assez vite et tu
vas arriver dans les temps c'est assez
bien indiqué au final le complexe le but
c'est pas que ce soit labyrinthe donc
c'est juste après le 3S 4S
donc je trouve assez vite la salle de
stockage
et donc vous vous arrivez avant lui
quand même dans salle de stockage vous
rentrez tous les trois
est-ce que vous faites dans cette salle
de stockage c'est une grande salle avec
beaucoup d'étagères d'armoires il y a
vraiment énormément d'outils de
d'appareils qui sont pas utilisés pour
l'instant et qui pourraient servir à
plein de blocs dans le le complexe
qu'est-ce que vous y cherchez alors
personnellement je sais pas trop ce que
je cherche mais des trucs qui va le
faire et du coup je pars d'un pas décidé
dans la direction opposée à eux en
disant moi ce que je cherche c'est par
là sur cette étagère et du coup je pars
je fais quelques rangées et je
m'engouffre dans une dérangées pour
essayer de choper des trucs avec ma
maladie
qu'est-ce que tu peux trouver je parle
un micro scope ça doit valoir un peu
cher quand même un bon micro stop
nickel tu te trouves peut-être un petit
PC un petit Mac un petit Mac ouais mais
format
ok ça je prends aussi ok
des bijoux qui traînent mais non
qu'est-ce qui pourrait traîner
les trucs qu'on met dans les déchets et
qui tournent j'adore
ton inventaire si tu veux ou dans ton
carnet comme tu préfères je sais pas
oublier du tout
[Musique]
mais j'aimerais bien que Fredo il y a
même place parce que c'est très haut et
ça me ça me fait mal au dos et c'est
vrai que pendant je repère quelques
truelles et j'en ai bien besoin parce
que il manque d'argent tout le temps sur
nos chantiers donc c'est vrai que si bon
je les emprunte je les ramènerai mais
voilà
on prend 10
c'est quelques quelques casques de
chantier voilà c'est un sac du coup pour
j'ai un cabas j'ai un peu de place là
sinon c'est vrai
[Musique]
la porte s'ouvre un peu avec fracas et
puis là je suis sportif entre dans la
salle donc tu vois trois personnes dans
la salle deux qui sont en train de
prendre des choses et lui qui est un peu
suspendu
monsieur monsieur petit oui Frédéric
j'ai j'ai un rendez-vous avec vous
c'est vous le je suis parti
alors
est-ce qu'on peut parler un petit peu en
privé peut-être sortir de dans la pièce
d'à côté
assez grand donc voilà donc on va se
mettre dans un le coin là bas si vous
voulez bien
tenez madame madame cupros
monsieur dites-moi
donc je m'éloigne de Madame cuprose
du plus possible donc je j'entraîne
monsieur petit par le bras alors
Monsieur petit
après je sais pas trop comment l'aborder
parce que là c'est pas évident
comment est-ce que je lui dis moi
monsieur petit est-ce que je peux lui
dire tu dis ce que tu veux que j'ai vu
ce que j'ai vu je peux pas pourquoi pas
après c'est toi qui vois
l'affaire que j'ai à vous présenter me
laisse circonspect moi je suis conscient
oui monsieur petit on va y aller assez
rapidement parce que je ne sais pas trop
ce que je fais là j'ai vu de mes yeux vu
un esprit une chose un fantôme peut-être
une émanation paranormale qui m'a dit de
venir vous retrouver ici à 15h48 je suis
venu ici à 15h48 maintenant c'est à vous
de vous exprimer
je suis pas magicien
d'esprits qui vous êtes qui d'abord
c'est quoi c'est un métier ça
non mon métier c'est président de la CCI
et humaniste
par contre je suis circonspect là je ne
sais pas comment me dégoter de cette
situation
comment faire
vous me dites que vous avez vu quelque
chose
un esprit qui vous a dit de venir me
voir à 15h48 il est
dites-moi ce que vous allez me dire il
est 15h48 et soudainement
les lumières deviennent rouges
j'ai perdu mes notes
la porte se ferme d'un coup il y a un
espèce de bruit de buzzer toi tu sais ce
que c'est c'est un confinement d'urgence
ça arrive parfois dans le complexe c'est
quand il y a un problème dans une
expérience dans n'importe quel sale
toutes les salles se servent
hermétiquement le temps d'être sûr de
désinfecter avant de rouvrir juste vous
inquiétez pas
de souci bon moi je fais je panique un
petit peu quand même parce que là
paranormal rouge que pour chiche il y a
pas de souci ça va se réouvrir ça arrive
souvent je suis pas rassuré parce que
j'ai peur que ce soit mon vol qui ait
déclenché et ces trucs là du coup je
suis un peu genre
c'est une expérience sûrement qui a fait
un peu de fumée il y a pas de quoi
s'inquiéter ça arrive souvent
il est un peu blafard monsieur
chicheporti vous allez bien
[Musique]
peut-être
je pense que je serai au courant si
jamais la moindre difficulté à oui très
bien je vais m'asseoir effectivement
ok donc tout va bien pour l'instant mais
d'un coup
c'est à dire que les lumières se mettent
à clignoter
et
une espèce de petite boule lumineuse
apparaît en l'air au milieu de la salle
c'est la même c'est la même que j'ai vu
c'est pas la même que tu as vu c'est
vraiment tout petit
pardon et ça bouge pas ça flotte en
l'air ok c'est tout quoi fait quelque
chose est-ce que je peux essayer de la
mettre dans ma valise ça va falloir
quelque chose non je sais pas essayer de
la mettre dans ta valise éventuellement
dis-moi comment tu t'y prends décris-moi
la situation c'est une petite bille qui
vole alors je prends ma valise je la
porte à bout de brasse qui n'est pas
évident vu qu'il y a déjà dedans
j'essaye de enfermer la boule dedans et
de refermer et voilà au moment où
Eglantine fait ça
vous entendez comme un bruit de tonnerre
un flash qui vous éblouit et glantine
n'est plus là
mais la bille est toujours là de lumière
je suis déjà morte
elle était là
et qu'est-ce que ces conneries là
j'essaie d'appeler Tom là ça répond pas
à partir c'est fermé il faut balayer la
zone il faut faire rayon par rayon comme
une stratigraphie
on l'a vu elle était là elle est plus là
tiens son rôle et que chacun se met là
vous vous êtes bien vous êtes bien là et
ben vous allez tout droit vous faites un
aller-retour on se retrouve ici vous
c'est vous c'est pareil moi je vais
rester là
ça va pas bien voilà tous les deux
oui on balaie on vérifie qu'elle soit
qu'elle est forcément quelque part les
esprits ça n'existe pas les disparitions
ça n'existe pas
vous deux vous balayer la zone chercher
un peu je suis assis tu es assis et je
regarde la boule tu la regardes tu es
assez près de la boule je suis à mi
distance
un peu bah oui je te dis je comprends
pas ce que c'est c'est impossible pas de
développement économique et c'est assez
étrange parce que malgré le fait qu'elle
soit d'un blanc immaculée pas du tout
alors que tu as l'impression que qu'une
grande lumière en émane
mais ça ne fait vraiment pas mal aux
yeux comme ça
donc tu sais pas trop ce qu'il y a vous
deux vous cherchez bon pas de trace de
églantine
mais il y a forcément une explication
rationnelle on vous dites ça
un coup d'éclair
faites moi un g de perception chacun
alors j'ai fait 20 sur 405 ok on Fredo
va voir c'est pareil s'il te plaît
donc moi là j'ai 52 sur c'est quoi j'ai
de vous dites quoi perception
et j'ai soif
52 oui c'est bon sur 70 pardon
vous avez eu la chance d'être tourné
dans le bon sens au moment où ce flash à
nouveau en fait vous avez vu un espèce
d'arc électrique partir de la boule vers
Pierre-Alain et la disparu oh oh
cette histoire
oui paintball
c'est grave quand même bah oui mais bon
moi j'ai mon papier qui se dégrade là il
faut quand même
c'est pas possible c'est quoi cette moi
je veux voir cette boule là c'est
bizarre je t'apprends de la boule je
m'approche de la boule qu'est-ce que tu
fais décris-moi
comme ça
je regarde la boule
je regarde et je fais ça ça brille ok
au moment il dit ça un éclair part de la
boule il disparaît
un petit peu toute seule
mais j'ai
j'ai beaucoup vécu et je c'est une
expérience de plus je
qu'est-ce que je dois qu'est-ce que tu
fais je suis toute seule dans cette
entreprise
je pense qu'il faut que je me protège
pour pas que ça m'arrive
parce que
alors vite une idée je pense qu'en fait
mes truelles me protègent je pense que
tout se m'étale et mon nom coupros qui
me vient de mon père Pierre coupros
forgeron grec spécialité dans le cuivre
ne me porte fait me quitte et je ne suis
pas superficieuse mais dans ces moments
là c'est vrai que bon c'est limite
limite donc je pense que toutes ces
ruelles en ceinture on doivent dévier
visiblement ces éclairs parce que sinon
je vois pas pourquoi j'aurais pas été
touché d'accord
mais quand même est-ce que tu fais de
quelque chose
spécifiquement juste tu t'es avec ta
ceinture de truelle et tu vas bien
la tête j'ai un peu peur quand même des
neurones
qu'est-ce que je peux faire est-ce que
je cherche ces gens
parce que bon il y a le temps passe et
je
c'est un choix cornélien parce que
est-ce qu'il faut le sauver le récit de
l'humanité ou trois individus ça c'est
un problème de front
pendant cette longue réflexion
la boule a grossi
et elle commence à lancer des éclairs
n'importe où dans la salle
lance des
espèces d'arc électrique qui partent
d'accord et qui touche des endroits de
la salle au hasard
je te dis que bon
oui il va falloir que je m'en aille je
pense quand même
qui avait la clé c'est Fredo il a
disparu
et pendant cette réflexion
je ne sais plus comment j'avais fait
pendant cette réflexion un éclair te
touche également tu disparais à ton tour
votre vision se déforme tous votre corps
ne vous répond plus des flashs de
lumière se font de plus en plus rapide
en premier lieu vous ne ressentez rien
de négatif mais à mesure que les flashs
s'accélèrent ces derniers vous assomme
et vous commencez à vous sentir de plus
en plus nauséeux et vous n'avez aucun
moyen de vous sortir de là
cette sensation croissante dure pour que
ce qu'il semble être une éternité puis
les flèches de lumière ralentissent
notre vision revient lentement à la
normale et vous commencez à retrouver
les sensations de vos membres une fois
que vous reprenez vos esprits vous vous
changez vous vous rendez compte que deux
personnes vous ont rejoint dans la salle
de stockage qui est désormais baigné
d'une lumière bleutée
et quelque chose cloche la salle n'a
plus rien à voir les étagères et autres
armoires ont laissé place à des machines
aux installations grossières vous êtes
assis sur des chaises derrière vous se
trouve une sorte de cuve de laquelle
s'échappe une légère fumée
vous êtes complètement déboussolé que ce
que cette histoire là
tout de suite
alors 31 sur 50
96 sur 45
74 sur 50
le carré en haut à droite
ah oui pardon
15 sur 75
les deux qui ont raté là vous tenez pas
le coup et vous vous mettez à vomir
toute votre RIP et vous perdez toutes
les deux un point de vue
oui
il y a du coup les deux personnes qui
ont l'air de vous avoir rejoint vous
comprenez pas ce qui vous arrive qui
sont
on est désolé on est désolé ils ont
l'air complètement paniqué de ce qui est
en train de se passer et vous êtes qui
là on est où ah non mais non mais c'est
catastrophique c'est pas possible
comment on a pu faire ça il y a
ils disent on est vraiment désolé
il y a un qui est plus âgé que l'autre
il dit vrai que je me présente je
m'appelle Gaston je vous a présente mon
apprenti Victor
et c'est catastrophique ce qu'on a fait
je sais pas comment on va vous renvoyer
chez vous en fait qu'est-ce que on est
où là au Casto vous êtes dans le
complexe Elixia oui ok et ben je suppose
que vous venez du passé quoi
vous venez de quelle époque vous on
vient de la salle A4s
on est mardi on est mardi Gaston tu vas
me dire quelle année
c'est l'année du renouveau c'est l'année
de réinventer Elixia tel qu'on la
connaît pour pouvoir prospérer dans tout
le monde c'est pas vous qui direz le
contraire monsieur chiche partout alors
là je suis pas vraiment en état de
parler développement économique je
cherche simplement à comprendre ce qui
nous arrive là
du passé vous venez de quelle année
écoutez je vous explique on voulait
ramener c'était un prototype on voulait
ramener des objets du passé de l'année
2023 on est en 2223
Joséphine le problème c'est qu'on
s'était dit qu'on allait viser la salle
de stockage en supposant que ça allait
prendre des objets pas des humains mais
il y a des gens qui vont dans les salles
de stockage pour reprendre de les objets
vous êtes tous pays oh là là vous êtes
cons alors là
ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est les
solutions
est-ce qu'on peut parler solution un
petit peu bah écoutez là tout de suite
on a pas de solution nous parce que le
concept de créer le prototype pour
faire avancer des choses dans le temps
alors ça marche je vais vous expliquer
quelque chose à tout problème il y a une
solution je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous monsieur il n'y a pas de
problème il n'y a que des opportunités
est-ce que je pourrais juste jeter un
œil à ma valise voir s'il y a encore mes
métros il y a tout ok c'est bon
est-ce qu'il y a une rue à mon nom dans
Elixia parce que tu veux qu'il y ait une
rue à ton endroit
qui s'appelle
vous vous me placez je connais la ruche
sportif
oui le sujet
bon écoutez je vous explique la
situation on a créé un prototype qui
déplace des objets du passé vers le
futur
est-ce que vous êtes en train de nous
traiter d'objet là Monsieur bah du coup
non mais le but c'était que ce soit des
objets apparemment ça déplace aussi des
êtres vivants ah bah oui oui apparemment
et c'est un miracle que vous soyez
encore en vie d'ailleurs
que mon excuser le problème c'est qu'on
a pas fait le prototype qui envoie les
gens dans le passé c'est beaucoup plus
dur et on n'a pas du tout encore
commencé à travailler dessus je vous
donne ma parole que à partir de
maintenant je vais te faire tout mon
possible que vous puissiez pour que vous
puissiez rentrer chez vous vous êtes sur
le fil rouge et le fil bleu
débranche tout on sait jamais
très bien écoutez excusez-moi pour
trouver une solution est-ce que je peux
prendre des notes pour que vous
m'expliquiez vous qu'est-ce qui vous est
arrivé alors déjà on va parler hôtel
accommodation tout ça et puis après
peut-être qu'on va parler voilà
il y a une grosse boule des éclairs
cette boule c'est une boule de lumière
qui brillait combien de circonférence la
taille d'une bille quoi oui vous voyez
moi
merci Monsieur
quand vous avez attrapé cette bille
c'était d'abord neutre et ensuite
c'était terrible et je n'ai plus senti
mes membres et la lumière clignotait et
après j'étais là et on peut parler des
dommagements maintenant
de vous loger vous nourrir avec grand
plaisir évidemment
en 200 ans là elle est devenue quoi
pendant que j'étais là hein elle est
devenue quoi votre start-up je sais pas
ce que c'est une start-up
et moi
j'osais tu ne petit entreprise très
dynamique créée par généralement des
jeunes un petit peu relou
j'ai oublié compte
non je ne sais pas comment enchaîner
allez-y
[Rires]
ce que je vous propose là déjà je vois
que ça vous a un peu remué surtout vous
deux je pense que la première chose à
faire ça va peut-être être vous remplir
l'estomac ah oui donc venez monsieur
psychologique peut-être aussi quand même
oui on pourra peut-être
mon ami Hugo va vous préparer un bon
repas venez avec moi
vous sortez du coup de la salle de
stockage vous marchez dans les couloirs
qui sont tous baignés d'une lueur
bleutée toi ça te fait très bizarre
parce que tu as l'habitude de travailler
dans ce couloirs en fait c'est pas
bleuté qu'à moitié parce que déjà la
lumière n'est pas la même et en plus tu
remarques que il y a vraiment beaucoup
de salles qui sont complètement laissées
à l'abandon d'élabrer etc alors que
d'autres sont toujours utilisés et bien
entretenu et ça fait un espèce de mix un
peu bizarre malaisant
les victoires dites-moi là le complexe
plus trop de monde
[Musique]
pour le coup écouter moi quand j'étais
moi je suis concierge ici moi je suis
concierge
oui vous étiez
oui c'est bon là on a compris 200 ans
moi je suis conscient je peux vous dire
que là ça c'est pas du bon travail vous
avez vu l'état des salles et bon on fait
ce qu'on peut il était très bon il s'est
bien son travail
avec vous
et voilà
vous arrivez du coup dans le l'espèce de
petit secteur enfin le lobby entre les
deux secteurs que tu es d'habitude une
salle de pause ou tu as l'habitude d'y
aller tranquillement ça a été
complètement retravaillé et tu as
l'impression que c'est une sorte de
restaurant genre il y a plein de tables
il y a une sorte de bar et il y a
derrière le bar du coup une sorte de
grande cuisine un peu ouverte avec un
grand gaillard et Gaston va le voir il
lui dit Hugo bon je te fais l'histoire
est très longue je sais pas comment
t'expliquer ça est-ce que tu pourrais
faire un petit repas sur ma note pour
mes quatre invités là
qu'est-ce que c'est la ce restaurant moi
de me souvenir ici c'était transition
secteur 3 secteur 4
et on devait passer c'est l'endroit où
on prend le métro quoi vous souvenez
madame français
j'ai bien compris qu'il y a 200 ans mais
pourquoi vous avez fait un restaurant
ici type pour nourrir les scientifiques
faut bien qu'ils mangent les pauvres
déjà qui doivent loger là-dedans et
commence
passer enfin bref
oui oui on vit ici nous on peut pas
vraiment vivre ailleurs en même temps
ce laboratoire
je suppose que vous vous êtes pas au
courant de la catastrophe c'est pour ça
qu'on visait 2023 vous me direz parce
que c'était avant il y a eu un crack
mes actions
une tête un peu normale j'ai
l'impression que c'est une sorte de
ragoût
semble pas forcément anormal de la
viande Hugo ou c'est un truc de
graines là
est-ce que vous voulez manger si oui qui
mange le repas alors moi je peux pas là
je mange moi il faut que je mange là ok
moi aussi c'est gratuit ok vous avez
tous l'impression que le goût est un peu
bizarre et vous vous dites que vu la
situation c'est peut-être normal que le
coup soit bizarre en fait je trouve que
vous faites pas plus de soucis que ça
pour l'instant
je sens que ça va finir vous vous
asseyez du coup sur une des tables il y
a d'autres scientifiques qui sont en
train de prendre des repas prendre des
petites pauses des verres d'eau etc il y
a pas mal il y a enfin pas mal un peu de
passage mais toi tu remarques que c'est
quand même beaucoup plus léger que à ton
époque genre pour toi genre le complexe
était extrêmement vivant là il y a des
gens mais c'est pas grave
Gaston il s'assoit avec vous il vous dit
bon écoutez va falloir que je vous
explique en gros le problème qu'on a bah
oui par pitié
pour faire simple comment dire il y a
une centaine d'années je dirais
bon moi ce qu'on m'a expliqué parce que
je suis né après
des particules noires se sont répandues
dans l'atmosphère du jour au lendemain
et en quelques jours on était plongé
dans la nuit
c'est à dire que
toutes les ondes lumineuses sont bloqués
et les ondes enfin les ondes
qui servent à communiquer également
donc on sait tous retrouver isolé
incapable de voir la moindre chose
incapable de s'éclairer à l'exception
avec et ça on a eu beaucoup de chance
la combustion de spolium l'élément qu'on
a découvert à Elixia il y a 150 ans
et du coup il vous pointe les lumières
en fait et vous remarquez que les
Lumières en fait c'est un peu bizarre
c'est pas juste des lumières un peu
comme des néons n'importe quelle lumière
que vous avez l'habitude mais en fait
c'est ça ressemble plus à un mix entre
une lumière électrique et une lanterne
qui brûle c'est comme si la combustion
était très lente c'est très agréable à
regarder et ça crée du coup une lumière
bleutée du coup vous explique c'est le
seul moyen qu'on a de s'éclairer
maintenant c'est le seul outil qui
repousse ces particules noires et qui
nous permet d'y voir quelque chose donc
vous doutez bien que l'humanité quand
elle a été incapable de
s'éclairer et de communiquer les uns
avec les autres à distance
bon la catastrophe était immense et on
suppose que les victimes se comptent en
millions voir en milliards
nous on a de la chance parce que parce
que les gens se cognaient beaucoup entre
eux c'est ça c'est que surtout pour se
nourrir sans se voir au bout d'un moment
ça devient compliqué
de venir d'un coup je pense que il y a
pas mal de gens qui malheureusement ne
survivraient pas les légumes qu'est-ce
que vous mangez là en fait
non mais en fait c'est assez bizarre
mais enfin les plantes se sont bien
adaptées assez vite en tout cas mais
toujours est-il que il y a eu une grosse
phase de crise le temps qu'on installe
le
Spadium en tant que ressources vitales
finalement nous on a eu beaucoup de
chance à horizon et dans le complexe
Elixia parce que c'est ici qu'elle a été
inventée donc c'est ici qu'elle a été
exporter en premier en fait donc du coup
on était pas mal déjà équipés en spolium
qui est une technologie qui du coup
de c'est du gisement
et ça a été inventé à Elixia et du coup
les premières productions étaient à
proximité d'horizon il y a pas de mine
de spoliant
et du coup il y a eu des exports ensuite
à travers le monde donc on suppose qu'il
y a des survivants ailleurs dans le
monde mais vu qu'on est dans
l'incapacité de communiquer avec qui que
ce soit on n'en sait rien donc nous on a
de la chance d'avoir quand même pas mal
de survivants mais bon c'est pour ça que
c'est assez d'élabré pas assez pour tout
maintenir en ordre genre on essaie de
survivre avant tout et notre objectif
c'est de trouver une solution contre ces
particules noires et un des axes exploré
c'est de récupérer un bout d'atmosphère
avant que les particules noires soient
dedans c'est le problème c'est que
maintenant
pas vous allez surtout nous ramener chez
nous là
il faut que ça avance
nous sommes paraît pas très
développement économique tout ça
on fait ce qu'on peut c'est
malheureusement alors solution du coup
est-ce qu'on peut en reparler donc
combien de temps à peu près ce que vous
pouvez nous renvoyer chez nous alors là
j'en sais rien parce que le prototype
j'y suis depuis quand même quelques
jours mais on a déjà la théorie du
prototype inverse par contre on n'a pas
encore de quoi le créer qu'est-ce qu'il
vous faut il vous faut un
[Rires]
macdotors n'hésitez pas j'en ai plein et
là j'ai mangé une poignée
vous nous renverrez nous et pas d'autres
gens votre famille
j'ai des valeurs j'ai fait une grosse
erreur qui a impliqué la vie d'être
humain qui aurait pu être catastrophique
je regrette amèrement et je veux réparer
les choses vous avez ma parole d'accord
donc tout va bien nous on se cale
quelque part voilà c'est des c'est des
petites vacances un peu délabrée c'est
ça je comprends bien
vous avez besoin d'aide Gaston si on
peut accélérer le process là c'est bon
ah oui je perçois
77 sur perception sur 40 OK
sur
on va arriver au bout d'un moment il y
en a bien un qui va réussir sinon tant
pis hein
il y a une horloge en fait dans la salle
je la vois et elle t'indique du coup il
est à peu près 16 heures
genre un petit peu avant 16h en fait
c'est à peu près l'heure du rendez-vous
de que tu avais dans le passé mais il y
a une fenêtre à côté et effectivement la
fenêtre tu as l'impression il fait nuit
dehors
de faire bien noir là
c'est le dehors c'est une fenêtre
l'hiver il fait pas de la poussière en
noir je sais pas avec les changements
d'horaires
je suis une vieille dame vous savez vous
vous terminez votre pâte tranquillement
et d'un coup claque
vous êtes dans le noir
alors j'essaye de vous entendez des voix
vous n'y voyez plus rien du tout
vous entendez des voix qui disent encore
ça commence à faire chier et tout
et là parce que vous avez quand même les
yeux grands ouverts
vous commencez à voir des espèces de de
lumière un peu trouble un peu comme si
vous avez déjà conduit de nuit dans du
brouillard je suppose que les gens
seront à peu près capables de situer que
vous voyez des phares d'une voiture au
loin au début vous voyez juste une
espèce de lueur un peu bizarre c'est à
peu près ce que vous voyez bleuté et
vous voyez pas ce qu'il y a
et au bout de quelques secondes
un lot de lumière qui écarte cette
espèce de brouillard noir et Gaston qui
tient une torche avec une Lure bleutée
qui vous dit bon désolé coupure de
courant bon pour pour vous puissiez vous
déplacer on veut je vais vous ramener je
vais vous en donner une comme ça vous
pouvez vous débrouiller sans moi si
jamais j'ai besoin de m'absenter pour x
ou y raison
et en fait là vous vous rendez compte
que du coup toutes les lumières que vous
voyez autour c'est d'autres gens avec
des torches qui se déplacent dans le
couloir donc la torche est notre moyen
de survie là faut pas la
Gaston il y en a une il vous dit
suivez-moi on va je vais vous en donner
vous êtes ok pour le suivre
à Gaston en passant oui de quoi c'est
fabriqué le spolium justement c'est de
synthèse vous fabriqués avec quoi alors
là j'ai pas la réponse en tant que MJ
parce que je compte tu as fait le sujet
plus tard pour d'autres épisodes je
pourrais te donner la réponse plus tard
j'ai une autre question
ça vaut cher ça se monnaie le spoiler
oui parce que en fait
la synthétisation enfin maintenant c'est
vital donc c'est à dire que juste c'est
au même niveau que l'eau en fait presque
concrètement vous voyez la nourriture
c'est si quelqu'un n'a plus de spolium
et bah il va devoir apprendre à vivre en
tant qu'aveugle mais c'est pas forcément
donné à tout le monde
ça reste possible
mais c'est compliqué ça se monnaie oui
ça se monnayer surtout avant quand on a
exporté etc maintenant il y a un peu
plus des accords
parce que c'est une denrée qu'on que les
gens en dépendent tellement que on
essaie de faire en sorte que les gens
vivent quand même un minimum on est dans
une situation de crise absolue le but
c'est pas de laisser les gens mourir
dans leur coin parce qu'ils peuvent plus
payer donc on essaie d'être un peu sympa
sur le sujet
ok je vois
j'en profite juste pour jeter un petit
œil aux dimensions de la torche et voir
si elle rentrerait dans ma mallette au
cas où oui d'accord merci
ok au bout d'un petit moment vous
commencez à avoir que en fait ça
s'accélère beaucoup autour de vous genre
vous croisez des gens qui courent
vraiment et qui ont regardé de plus en
plus paniqué et limite ça crie dans une
salle au loin et vous savez pas pourquoi
genre il y a des espèces d'ordre qui
sont à faire ça machin vite dépêche-toi
machin truc dans le genre
là où vous vous rendez vous vous rendez
et Gaston il commence à pas être serein
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a eu un cri là moi j'ai entendu
d'un coup il y a une femme qui entre
dans connaître ça dans votre petite
petite dame de de visibilité qui rentre
avec sa torche et qui dit Gaston je
cherchais partout j'ai absolument besoin
de toi je t'explique la l'expérience sur
laquelle on est là on avait absolument
besoin d'électricité pour maintenir le
système ça ça peut exploser l'autre si
on la réalimente pas là on a des gens
qui sont en train de faire tourner des
dynamos mais on va pas pouvoir tenir
très longtemps
tu coupes concrètement
comment ça se dit quoi et d'un coup il
prend un énorme coup de stress et vous
voyez qui perd ses moyens
et la femme
tu veux dire un truc
je sais pas trouve des gens pour aller
voir le générateur et va demander aux
Aigles rouges de mettre leur système de
secours en attendant et elle s'en va
vous êtes le rouge ça me rappelle une
chanson l'Aigle Noir ce que vous la
connaissez
ma montre qui BIPE là enfin je suis en
alerte critique
tout ça il y a rien qui va quoi ok
je suis venu un petit peu en précipité
donc j'ai pas vraiment bien bien
organisé mon rendez-vous pour une fois
normalement je suis plutôt au carré mais
là du coup j'ai rien j'ai ma montre qui
sonne mon cœur qui s'emballe moi je
juste besoin de me caler quelque part là
et qu'on reprenne tout ça demain quoi si
possible je vais vous calmer un matin ou
peut-être
une nuit
alors
est-ce qu'on peut la faire taire parce
que là moi ça va plus du tout de
stimulation
trop de stimulations
madame couper je fais vraiment ce que ce
que je peux là je suis au maximum
s'il vous plaît trouvez-moi un endroit
ou mettre ou me poser et laissez-moi
Gaston
nous une torche au Gaston
est-ce que par pur hasard vous
accepteriez d'aller voir ce qui se passe
au générateur géothermique c'est pas
très loin c'est en une heure vous allez
faire les retours je pense peut-être
1h30 mais il se dit je prends le métro
Gaston toi tu as un petit tilt quand il
parle d'un générateur géothermique
bah oui le générateur tu géothermique
mais c'est moi c'est le mien c'est
c'est moi qui l'ai c'est moi qui l'ai
fait il s'appelle comment le ça te
rassure un peu bah oui je me dis oui
quand même et puis je connais quoi c'est
vous savez y aller alors ah bah je sais
y aller du coup là je retrouve un petit
peu mes moyens parce que bon voilà c'est
quand je suis un peu plus en confiance
ça oui oui je sais je sais comment y
aller bien sûr
ben du coup je vous amène oui
d'abord Gaston vous donne une torche
pour le groupe à moi à toi ok il te
montre comment on met une batterie en
gros c'est des espèces de petits
cylindre que tu mets en comme des
recharges et ça alimente le ça sert de
combustible et ça alimente l'attend
donc voilà donc tu attends c'est bon et
il vous dit écoutez il y a un raccourci
ça va beaucoup plus vite que que le
chemin et puis vous risquez de vous
perdre parce que c'est c'est un peu
compliqué là en ce moment
il vous explique vous dit en gros vous
sortez du du complexe par derrière le
secteur 5 ouais je vois que tu le sais
je vois très bien vous prenez le chemin
pendant 20 30 mètres jusqu'à arriver au
pied du mont Nivelles vous longer et
vous avez une espèce d'entrée de galerie
et dans cette galerie il y a un ça mène
tout de suite il y a une sortie de la
galerie en fait qui mène au générateur
ça va beaucoup plus vite que n'importe
quel chemin il prend une carte qui sort
il vous dit tenez la sortie c'est là il
vous la donne il part en courant
salut Gaston donc on y va vous donner
cette carte
c'était ma fouille
alors c'est peut-être pas le même
endroit de ta fouille et je te le dire
tout de suite ce ne sera pas le même
endroit de ta fouille mais oui le monde
niveau c'est sur un de ces flancs où il
y a d'accord il pourrait pas aller jeter
un petit œil un exemplaire chacun de la
carte qui vous a donné avec la sortie
qu'il est entourée petit problème
il a oublié de vous dire où c'est
l'entrée
en régie ça va vous montrer la carte que
eux ils voient donc c'est une carte
juste un rond rouge qui indique la
sortie sauf que eux n'ont aucune idée de
quelle galerie et l'entrée vous les
viewers vous verrez un peu plus
d'informations vous verrez les mêmes
informations que moi
ok donc bon apparemment on a une coupure
de son donc désolé on est revenu je vais
peut-être répéter pour peut-être qu'on a
entendu mais dans le doute je vais
répéter donc les joueurs ils ont une
carte où ils n'ont que un rond rouge en
régie vous pouvez l'afficher tout de
suite du coup ils savent où est la
sortie mais ils ne savent pas où est
l'entrée ils vont le voir trouver leur
chemin vous on va vous montrer une carte
où vous avez toutes les informations
donc vous savez où est l'entrée vous
savez qu'est-ce qu'ils vont rencontrer
sur les chemins et vous allez pouvoir un
peu vous amuser de voir les voir se
perdre à travers ses galeries
pour vous expliquer le chat ça je suis
pas sûr que vous allez voir mais je vais
essayer de montrer à chaque fois que je
change de carte on va jouer avec des
cartes qui indiquent l'état d'énergie de
votre torche sur 5
donc là tu as une batterie neuve donc tu
as 5 avec le temps forcément ça s'amuse
si vous n'avez plus d'énergie c'est le
noir et faire tout noir
donc c'est à vous de voir de bien
réfléchir à votre torche c'est un peu
votre
c'est un peu votre barre de vie de là en
fait finalement voilà et donc je la je
prends cette torche en responsabilité
très bien
je me demande on m'avait demandé de
faire une petite pause en milieu
d'aventure je pense que ce serait
peut-être un bon moment parce que ça va
peut-être être un peu long les galeries
est-ce que vous voulez faire la pause
maintenant ou on fait les galeries et on
fait la pause après je retire
c'est comme vous voulez hein
j'ai touché le micro désolé
donc vous entrez dans la galerie vous
n'y voyez pas grand chose vous voyez
juste à deux trois mètres devant en fait
c'est vraiment comme un tome où vous
voyez et après un mur noir en fait donc
c'est vraiment c'est très spécial
à l'infini jusqu'ici s'amenuise petit
c'est juste comme une façade d'un coup
brumeuse
donc restez près de nous s'il vous plaît
et vous tombez sur une intersection ça
part à gauche ou à droite qu'est-ce que
vous faites mon intuition
on a une démocratie
je tiens la torche en responsabilité je
vous le rappelle donc on va aller à
droite une fois sur deux vous vous
décidez ensuite nous décide on va aller
voir écouter
maladroit et vous tombez sur un chemin
de fer en fait un vieux chemin de fer
donc je posais des rails d'une ancienne
mine finalement qui ont été un peu
recouverts par la terre et il y a un
endroit où juste la terre se creuse et
du coup ça révèle un peu les rails
ça se prononce sur quelques mètres
ou juste vous les suivez est-ce que je
peux lécher la terre juste tu peux
lécher la terre alors je lâche la
terreuse très bien
si vous voulez
archéologique je vous prends bien
volontiers complètement fou je continue
avec ma torche donc là je dirige un peu
mais un peu voilà enfin je suis les
rails les rails finissent par se
ensevelir sous la terre à nouveau et
vous tombez à nouveau sur une
intersection ça continue tout droit ou
alors ça tourne à gauche
est-ce que vous le suivez vous voulez
l'arrêter on va pas le perdre
ok
parce que là je suis en responsable
voilà
à gauche à gauche merci on est peut-être
ici moi je regarde la carte alors
c'était gauche ou tour donc on n'est pas
là on serait peut-être là
on a le droit tout gauche là on pourrait
tout droit bah oui
on est on est on est pas bien
non mais on marche on marche
on regarde la carte
de toute façon
ok donc vous continuez tout droit et
vous tombez à nouveau sur l'intersection
à droite ou tout droit ah je crois que
je l'ai
super enfin voilà je me dirige tout
droit moi en tout cas tout droit il faut
qu'on sorte
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut éviter de
tourner vous continuez votre chemin
vous tombez à nouveau sur l'intersection
gauche ou droite mais vous commencez à
entendre des bruits au loin de gens qui
parlent à gauche ou à droite
ben ça résonne un peu du coup en fait tu
as l'impression tu as l'impression de
partout mais tu te doutes que non pas de
partout et puis tu saurais pas dire de
où ça vient mais tous me faire un g de
perception
avec un petit malus de 20 donné par les
viewers
[Musique]
sur
45 donc il a fallu que je fasse
250 j'ai 30 sur 40 mais avec le malus ça
passe pas alors que pourtant je suis
très bien et moi tu me demandes pas
67 + le malus sur 40 du coup vous
n'entendez pas vraiment qu'est-ce que
c'est le côté
les voix mais vous savez vous avez pas
capable de s'engage d'un côté et on
essaie d'appeler et voici
on part à gauche on s'avance un peu sur
la gauche parce que si on fait à droite
est-ce qu'on peut dire Marco
s'arrêtent
d'un coup dès que vous parlez est-ce que
je propose qu'on essaie de chanter
il y a un problème
on va quand même un problème avec mais
c'est pas grave alors du coup je propose
qu'on fasse silence
ce soir arrêtez de parler ce qui nous a
entendu
chaleureux
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
tu dis juste bonjour
c'est Jésus qui vous parle
Jésus
non mais miauler
tu fais du bruit de chat là
s'il vous plaît
je suis le
monsieur de la rue
vous venez de la part de qui t'entends
une voix qui résonne
là
il faut que tu ailles à la centrale oui
mais moi je me rappelle que de Gaston
moi je me souviens de l'aigle rouge on
vient voir les Aigles rouges oui il
essaie oui
si jamais vous avez mal compris
vous pouvez quand même parler des aigles
rouges il y a pas de souci juste on
vient du complexe Elixia la part de
Gaston c'était scientifiques
oui oui de ce qui fait les balles
vous vous tiendrez pas une semaine en
Amazonie ah oui non mais j'ai pas prévu
de le faire
on arrive
est-ce qu'on peut dire Marco moi je
propose on touche le mur sur la gauche
on revient en arrière on se cache
à l'intersection mais surtout
on touche le mur comme ça on sait où on
est on recule jusqu'à intersection et on
se lance
vous vous mettez dans le l'autre
intersection en fait
on revient
en arrière oui
et vous vous mettez vers là où vous êtes
pas enfin de là où vous venez pas ou de
là où vous
ah ben oui quand même on n'est pas
foufou oui ok
vous vous en sortez à peu près vous
entendez des bruits de pain qui se
rapprochent de vous
ce serait de retourner au rail et la
terre on se met sous la terre comme ça
par terre
attention mon cœur quoi
et au bout d'un moment les bruits de
passe éloignent vous avez aucune idée de
s'ils sont passés devant vous ou pas ou
ailleurs vous êtes incapable de le dire
parce que vous n'y voyez rien du tout et
les grosses résonnent trop vous ne
pouvez pas savoir si vous les avez
croisé ou non vous avez échappé à la
mort ou non je vous juste de partir en
catimini
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
je remets la batterie
je pense qu'on peut remettre la batterie
oui je remets la batterie
section où vous étiez parti à gauche
six sommes partis à droite et qu'on les
suit c'est peut-être pas la bonne idée
sinon reviens sur nos pas et on refait
tout le chemin et on part de l'autre
sens à gauche
stratégique de ma part depuis tout le
début ou en responsabilité j'ai pris ma
torche je suis parti à droite il faut
les suivre
[Musique]
qui viennent de quelque part moi c'était
ça l'idée
sur la violence
ils étaient là où on voulait aller
forcément ils sont partis ailleurs et du
coup on peut rentrer
je pense oui moi je suis d'accord avec
Madame évident parce que ils sont partis
il faut aller vers où ils étaient
oui c'était voilà oui d'accord il faut
suivre là faut qu'on se faut qu'on
s'écoute nous sommes ensemble
tout droit à gauche ou à droite
on intersection
je pense que tout droit
qu'on essaye de tourner le moins
possible sinon on va faire des tours de
rond-point là tout droit
jamais je vous ai pas dit mais vous
pouvez écrire sur la carte je voulais
donner c'est
un peu complexe
tout droit et au bout d'un moment vous
voyez que vous commencez à marcher un
peu dans l'eau dans une eau un peu
boueuse concrètement et plus vous
avancez plus ça s'enfonce
et vous vous tombez sur une intersection
où ça part à gauche ou à droite mais ça
s'enfonce
non mais votre costard ça s'enfonce ah
tu vois juste de l'eau et en fait je
sais pas en fait c'est très beau du coup
tu sais pas la profondeur juste tu vois
que la mesure que tu as avancé ça a
commencé à monter sur tes chevilles
peut-être
on a fait pour l'instant on est un peu
tout droit on a fait droite gauche et
que du tout droit
donc a priori
et là on peut faire quoi
la gauche ou droite
on est là si on est là
on a fait ça d'accord
le premier pouvait aller que à droite ou
à droite c'est le seul c'est sans
surprise quoi voilà
on est du côté gauche vous serez là moi
je pense que il faudrait qu'on aille à
droite on est bien loin
moi j'ai le bras qui qui
voulait que je prenne le relais
on est loin
ça crée des tours c'est un peu longtemps
que il faut garder
en plus
et l'énergie de la torche ça m’amuse un
petit peu on va passer à 4 sur 5 on
pense avoir une piste avec Madame cupros
je pense qu'on a l'opposé de là où on
devrait aller vraiment pas faire
raison on ne sait où on est donc on
serait à l'opposé
c'est tu sais on va pas dans le même
sens
on serait ici
on fait demi-tour on risque de croiser
les autres oies
vous savez pas du tout où on est vous
savez pas je tenais la torche madame bon
je pense on part à droite il faut se
décider sinon on va se retrouver dans le
noir
dans le doute
vous
tombez à nouveau
la boue là ont juste on passe au final
oui ça ça s'enfonce un peu et ça je
remonte mais vous sortez de l'eau
sur la droite vous tombez sur
l'intersection qui part soit à gauche
soit à droite et vous entendez des
sortes de jappement d'un chien ils
viennent de la droite à l'intersection
vous allez vers le chien
ou alors
c'est une des autres sorties c'est déjà
pas assez ou entrée
il y en a une c'était la bonne entrée
oui et les autres on ne sait pas tu sais
pas ce que ça va faire est-ce qu'on peut
qualifier les jappement
effrayé
non ceci dit si là il y a bien une
entrée qu'on est ici elle est pas très
loin oui on peut aussi aller voir on
peut aller voir
on fait quelques mètres il y a une
entrée une sortie bon on peut regarder
ce qu'il en ressort oui c'est vrai
rien à déjà ok
vous tombez sur une intersection gauche
ou droite
moi je suis encore perdu hein
il faut dire qu'on ne sait pas et je ne
sais pas on revient en arrière on va
voir le problème
c'est comme ça on va voir le chien
bon on fait ça les copains ok je me
permets fait demi-tour et vous allez
vers là où vous avez entendu bruit du
chien et vous tombez sur un vieux chien
un peu boueux
effrayé quand il vous voit il s'approche
de vous tout doucement
alors qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
c'est un chien comme les chiens de 2023
[Musique]
alors on file
pas les monstres mais on va vers lui
donne tous les cas oui voilà c'est ça
moi je me baisse
vous êtes trop gentil Frédo vous êtes
trop gentil
contre toi
un espèce de colis un peu bizarre en
fait tu fais le lien assez vite
parce que dans ce collier il y a
toujours une sorte de compartiment et
c'est quand tu l'ouvres en fait c'est
une recharge de spolium
lui permettait de s'éclairer du coup il
s'est retrouvé perdu dans ces galets
c'est éteint
juste perdu c'est un chien qui a pas de
dorade du coup
non pareil il est dans une galerie
[Musique]
de ce que vous voulez adopter le chien
oui il va nous suivre de toute façon moi
il me connaît
si jamais
servir de bouclier
très bien vous continuez le chemin vous
tombez sur une intersection ça va tout
droit à gauche ou à droite et à gauche
le tunnel et bloqué par une sorte de
palissade en bois
je me précipite vers la palissade et je
la lèche et elle a quel goût
de chêne
en 2232 il poussera encore du chêne bah
c'est très résiste
une grosse palissade quoi
mais c'est non mais c'était une question
donc on n'est pas obligé d'être par là
non enfin le but c'est quand même de
sortir un moment donné je veux dire il
nous aurait pas envoyé sur une palissade
c'est vous qui êtes devant bon moi je
veux juste sortir que ce soit clair moi
j'essaye là je suis là et je vois que
des problèmes
j'aimerais bien me poser l'oreille sur
la palissade
je tente le coup d'épaule tu vois à
travers
un jeu de force
76 sur 75 alors ça craque et ça ne brise
pas j'aurai
est-ce que les autres veulent faire un
truc avant peut-être l'aider
sportive donc je vais y aller et je vais
lui dégainer un coup de kickflip du pied
talon
directement dans la palissade d'accord
fais-moi
un
anglicisme corporel combien en dextérité
j'ai 40
non fais-moi force
j'ai 45 ce sera toujours
et j'ai des ballerines
21 tu fais un kickflip et tu exploses la
palissade
en ayant toujours la tanche dans la main
bravo ma petite on prend des risques
merci
vous voulez aller vers ce chemin je
suppose ou alors on y va
le plaisir de casser les choses voilà
côté révolutionnaire ok du coup bon vous
avancez on est d'accord euh vous suivez
le chemin c'est assez long
et vous tombez sur une intersection où
ça va à gauche ou droite
toujours la même réponse voilà
c'était long donc si c'est long est-ce
que à gauche palissade
je suis perdu je me dis c'est long il a
dit c'est long c'est le plus long des
bras à droite en même temps
si on fait gauche droite tout le temps
c'est pas logique qu'on fasse toujours
droite on tient un CAP en fait
pour sortir dans labyrinthe ou d'une
situation politique compliquée il faut
tenir le meilleur
choix privilégié quand c'est
particulièrement compliqué et aussi un
peu compliqué à ce moment là on peut un
peu
on en discutera plus tard voilà il faut
avancer
le problème c'est que ça fait deux fois
qu'on va à gauche donc et oui mais donc
si on est là
on va voir où ça va nous mener
le problème c'est qu'il y a c'est pas
comme un labyrinthe
en fait c'est pas on va tout le temps
en fait si on fait pour toi mais c'est
vrai que si on tient toujours un côté au
bout d'un moment on fera tous les murs
de toute la surface non on va pouvoir
faire un tour il y a des endroits de la
solution on peut tourner on pourrait
même le faire sans lumière challenge
j'aime ces mots
maintenant je vous je vous parie qu'on
peut sortir sans lumière mais bon
je serai David d'aller à droite je le
sens bien si on est là parce que
longtemps qu'on marche c'est le segment
le plus long écoutez monsieur Fredo
c'est parti ou partir à droite et au
bout d'un moment
vous rendez compte que la grotte
s'élargit et vous commencez à nouveau à
sentir la chaleur du soleil même si vous
ne pouvez toujours pas voir la lumière
du soleil ah c'est flippant ça quand
même le soleil donc vous savez que vous
êtes à l'extérieur indirectement on a
l'extérieur oui vous avez réussi à
sortir
donc là on est dehors est-ce que ça
change quelque chose enfin on voit des
trucs différents comme vous voyez un peu
d'herbe par terre par exemple
et le chien il réagit comment
avec vous
[Musique]
oui pour rigoler alors votre entrée je
vous montre un peu
c'était là en bas donc si vous le tenez
avec la sortie en haut c'était au milieu
en bas
du coup vous êtes allé à droite vous
avez vu les chemins de fer et continuer
là je vais te monter ici vous avez
croisé enfin peut-être croiser les
individus
vous avez continué de là vers l'eau
remonter ici un petit aller-retour là
puis vous étiez au chien la barricade
ça vous avez pris pas mal de temps quand
même du coup 5400 hop voilà et c'est
intéressant cette montre
vous voulez récupérer la torche alors
j'esquive un petit peu le regard là
parce que je trouve des boîtes
pour info ils ont pris encore un peu de
temps à sortir de la grotte du coup on
baisse encore le niveau d'énergie de la
torche de 1 donc on passe à 3 est-ce que
nous on le voit cette information c'est
un petit cadran avec des petites cartes
sur le petit bar euh la technologie ça
fait un petit peu peur
du coup est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse la pause maintenant ou est-ce que
on y va jusqu'au bout c'est comme vous
voulez
c'est parti c'est parti on y va jusqu'au
bout ça va
plus de pause quoi qu'il arrive
du coup vous sortez des galeries et en
sortant des galeries vous tombez assez
vite sur un grillage
donc qui est relié au bord de la falaise
du monde nivez du coup dequel vous venez
de sortir et qui s'étend dans une
direction est-ce que vous voulez faire
quelque chose alors
normalement moi je me souviens qu'à
l'époque de la construction de parce que
là on est pas loin de thermique
donc là je vais un petit peu sur la
gauche là et là il y a une espèce de box
si c'est comme il y a 200 ans et
enfin il y a une boîte non il y a pas de
boîte il y avait une boîte avant il y
avait une boîte voilà je connaissais le
code bon bah
extrêmement bien parce que c'est un site
du foot dans lequel tu travailles du
coup tu es un peu plus sur le terrain
que Pierre-Alain en fait tu te rends
compte que non c'est pas là qui se
construisait le générateur
ne capte pas pour lui c'est ici
c'est là pour le coup je pense que je
suis mieux placé que vous pour le savoir
j'ai travaillé sur ce terrain
d'architecte que j'avais commandé divisé
monsieur chiche parti j'ai passé des
heures j'ai j'ai creusé la terre sur ce
lieu là si c'était l'endroit de mon
chantier pardonnez-moi je retrouverai de
la rubalise du Bidim qui très longtemps
il y a rien de tout ça là quand on
peu importe le boîtier n'est plus là
donc ce n'est pas là vous vous suivez le
grillage du coup bah moi je regarde au
loin pour voir le boîtier
tu vois pas plus loin d'accord
là ça me peine un peu de la remettre
mais je me souviens de sous-traitant qui
a fait ce grillage là c'était pas super
cher c'est pas de l'acier non plus voilà
je peux vous
on l'a un peu fait pas cher le grillage
à l'époque
si tu le dis
je le dis c'est moi les factures je les
ai encore et on ne peut pas
moyen
s'il était pas très cher le grillage
mais on peut passer dessous peut-être on
va pas creuser le chien
c'est peut-être ça la vraie question
trouver le boîtier on trouve le boîtier
je rentre le code et on rentre et voilà
on peut suivre le grillage jusqu'à ce
qu'on voit quelque chose
ce que les codes comme ça ça change
jamais
normalement vous longer le grillage et
vous finissez par tomber sur la
portail du grillage en fait qui est
ouvert ah pas besoin de code parfait et
il y a une sorte mais je connais le code
je vous tiens voilà une sorte de sentier
toujours pas d'autres lumières non non
donc ça on est d'accord c'est le sentier
qui va centrale géothermique là tu
suppose bah moi je reconnais ça
ressemble et pas
30 chemin
tu es sûr que tu as pas travaillé ici
bah je reconnais pas mais bon
après il y a pas trop le chemin
effectivement
vous progressez sur ce qui semble être
le chemin qui relie la barrière à la
porte d'entrée du générateur
le halo de votre torche de spodium finit
par révéler ce qui ce qui semble être
une grande double porte en acier
certainement la porte dont vous a parlé
Gaston et contrairement à ce qui vous le
avez dit cette dernière est ouverte
et une odeur de faire provient de
l'Intérieur pardon une odeur de fer
[Musique]
est-ce que vous entrez ou non
on est venu pour parler le générateur
donc après moi je suis pas trop comment
on va la réparer
on suit monsieur Fredo est-ce qu'on peut
entrer en laissant le chien en train de
nous au cas où le chien il a pas envie
de rentrer le chien
et Pierre-Alain à l'entrée en fait le
gay mais on n'aura pas de lumière
madame couper je vois bien ce que vous
essayez de
d'essayer
on a eu nos différents maintenant je
pense qu'il est temps de de passer outre
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait coopérer un
petit peu l'odeur de fer c'est pas bien
méchant
c'est pas le genre de signal
que vous entrez
dans le hall d'entrée du bâtiment
l'odeur de fer se fait de plus en plus
étouffante puis vous finissez par tomber
sur la source de cette dernière un
cadavre allongé dans une flaque de sang
j'enfonce le sol au centre de la pièce
c'était donc moteur de faire je lèche le
nom
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on regarde un peu ce cadavre
j'approche la torche pour voir un petit
peu de quoi il en retour c'est une femme
c'est une femme type de blessure
qu'est-ce que je vois qu'est-ce que
j'arrive à voir tu vois qu'elle a été
blessée par balle
enfin blessé
et autour on est dans une grande salle
il y a pas de dans un couloir et des
portes ouais qu'est-ce que je veux en
fait sur ta gauche quand tu rentres il y
a une salle sur ta droite donc en face
de cette porte il y a une autre salle
tout au fond genre c'est un peu comme un
hall d'entrée tout au fond il y a une
grande double porte qui est fermée à
gauche tu vois des escaliers avant cette
porte et en face des escaliers il y a
une porte en fer ferme
à la morte pour savoir un peu à quoi
elle ressemble est-ce qu'elle aura un
badge marqué hello my name is
un peu toujours
ça te retourne pas trop l'estomac donc
tu trouves
que genre une espèce de badge où il y a
marqué son nom elle s'appelle Louise
Johnson elle s'appelait du coup
et tu trouves rien de spécial sur elle à
part ça d'accord
est-ce que je peux elle a été blessée
par balle de combien de balles une dans
la jambe et une dans la poitrine alors
je prends mon index et je fouille les
plaies et je récupère les balles parce
que ça peut servir
[Musique]
deux balles exploser du coup je les mets
dans ma mallette avec les Égypte
vous voulez
non ça ira comme ça je vous remercie je
suis habile qu'est-ce qu'on fait
sur les plantes en tout cas petite
escalier couloir petit escalier qui
monte droite gauche petit escalier qui
descend quelque chose comme ça c'est
très pratique
non c'est pas ça du tout vous souvenez
plus alors donc dans ce cas là c'est
peut-être couloir choisissez une salle
bon bah celle-là
sur la gauche
vous entrez et vous tombez sur un autre
cadavre qui est étalé sur une table
alors là sur une table on va on va
peut-être éviter de s'il vous plaît un
peu de tenue
par balle
on approche la torche alors cette fois
tu as vu les plans et du coup tu
reconnais la salle c'est la salle du
gardien c'est lui qui est censé gérer
l'ouverture des portes etc c'est la
salle du gardien c'est là qui est censé
gérer les portes et tout c'est pas un
très bon boulot
alors peut-être que il y a des boutons
pour ouvrir allumer je sais pas si la
salle du gardien
pas de courant vu que le générateur il
en rade peut-être sur un mur un plan du
bâtiment que vous avez
un peu flou quand même et en 220 ils ont
peut-être eu des changements
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur
petit regardons cherchons un plan
chercher la seule vous trouvez pas
spécialement de plan la pièce
je cherche le il a bien un bureau le
gardien oui je cherche dans ces tiroirs
s'il a pas des armes parce que c'est un
gardien donc il peut peut-être se
défendre ou il y a pas d'armes par
contre tu vois que il avait un
port je sais pas comment ça s'appelle un
truc pour ranger un pistolet
ok vous voyez le fouiller le gardien ou
pas
il avait un espèce de colis avec un
badge sauf que il y a plus le bout du
coup enfin tu comprends que c'est un
collier avec un badge au bout sans le
badge du coup mais nous on a un match
on a déjà on l'a récupéré le petit badge
sur le sur l'autre personne ou pas
c'était pas vraiment face à c'était plus
une carte
vous voyez parce que pareil il a
l'espèce de petit truc avec marqué son
nom c'est Adrien Durand mais
du coup il avait un badge vu que c'est
le gardien c'est lui qui peut ouvrir les
salles mais il n'a plus sur lui
alors je prends le collier qui tient le
badge on sait jamais ok je vais mettre
dans ma seconde
à une scène terrible terrible parce que
c'est encore une fois beaucoup beaucoup
de problèmes très peu de solutions
de moins en moins de solution
on y va on y va pas là parce que ça
commence à être un petit peu chaud notre
histoire
marchand
sortez de la pièce et vous entendez
quelqu'un vous appelez à dans la pièce
d'en face qui a pas l'air bien manqué
grand chose donc vous galérez un peu là
la suite
ok et tu tombes sur un homme qui est un
peu baigné don du sang encore conscient
dans son sang c'est une hécatombe
avec eux on est d'accord je croyais que
vous étiez avec eux qu'est-ce qui vous
est arrivé là je le prends par le col là
position latin de sécurité tu fais ça
vous voyez bien vous êtes docteur
rouge ok donc il dit bah je sais pas
ceux qui étaient avec des Caps là je
sais pas ils sont arrivés ils ont tué
tout le monde
extrêmement paniqué et pas loin de
tomber dans les pommes bon moi j'ai ma
montre kiwip encore
rouge
ok je mange ok premier soin premier soin
d'accord et bien
j'ai besoin d'aide qu'est-ce que je fais
je jette les dés et je fais 44 sur
c'est quoi le premier soir
ah sur 65
il vous dit moi je suis pas capable de
marcher il faut absolument rallumer le
générateur la vie de milliers de
personnes en dépend
sur vous il est où ce générateur quand
vous appelez vous êtes dedans il vous
donne un badge son badge je mets sur le
collier
et je te donne un Fredo
de tes trucs et tu as le badge du
générateur
qui vous donne ça
il vous dit moi je sais pas le rallumer
mais je sais que dans les archistes
techniques il y a des schémas qui
expliquent comment ça marche
alors il va scier un peu là il est pas
bien écoute mon brave
et il est où le générateur incapable de
marcher vraiment il a porté ouais
il nous faut les réponses elles sont où
les archives il est où le générateur
sont au moins un le cœur du générateur
c'est derrière la double porte
après les escaliers il va falloir
rallumer le courant avant
je crois je sais plus comment ça mais
comment on peut allumer le générateur ça
a aucun sens je suppose que c'est
expliqué dans les archives techniques
moi je suis pas technicien désolé je
peux pas vous dire il faut qu'on aille
moi je connais c'est plein de tout c'est
plein de techniques là d'accord donc je
pense qu'il faut aller aux archives
documents
utiles
on est en plein dedans et bien on y va
ça va aller mon brave
bureau
on le cache pour pas que voilà ils
reviennent humaniste
avant tout voilà ok donc vous allez vers
les escaliers pour descendre - anges
c'est oui c'est ça ok donc vous
retrouvez au moins un et là vous voyez
un petit plan du -1 donc vous savez
qu'il y a il fait froid
la salle des machines
la salle de stockage des archives
techniques et la salle du transformateur
électrique
alors
je pense qu'il faut aller aux archives
avant tout parce que sinon ce sera pas
ce qu'il faut faire bah c'est ce qui
nous a dit de faire c'est ce qui nous a
dit de faire suivre les consignes
problème solution on y va vous allez
vous archives techniques archive
technique bon il y a plein d'étagères
avec
plein de
dossiers avec des fiches etc et vous
voyez un truc où il y a marqué en cas
d'urgence
est-ce que ça nous concerne vraiment
pourquoi on est là
je pense qu'il est urgent de sortir de
là vu comment on finit les gens
très bien
la personne que vous avez sauvée à
l'étage du dessus des lavis de milliers
de personnes dépend de ce générateur ah
oui non mais nous on les connaît
relativement peu mais
c'est pour ça que là je vous rejoins là
dessus humaniste
moi j'attrape le truc le dossier tu
trouves ça
je trouve ça parce que les autres aussi
vous voulez regarder alors bien sûr je
vous montre c'est un fonctionnement
de une centrale à cycle combiné ça
explique comment fonctionne
la centrale générateur de secours
séparateur turbine
c'est compliqué
pas loin malheureusement vous êtes là
Fredo parce que
je pense que il faut qu'on aille dans la
salle du transformateur c'est ici si on
n'a pas le transformateur on lui aura
que dalle ok vous suivez Fredo
jusqu'au bout du monde
ce n'est pas notre domaine de compétence
nous nous remettons entièrement de
compétences humaniste
le développement économique vous allez
dans la salle du transformateur bon
c'est très bien indiqué du coup vous
voyez en suivant avec votre torche sur
les murs un peu des flèches qui indique
vers où c'est vous finissez par trouver
la salle donc c'est une salle avec
beaucoup de machines et sur un des murs
il y a un grand panneau électrique
qui a été forcé tu vois que le truc qui
tenait il est pété
et sur le dessus sur la façade de ce
panneau il y a une lune noire
et en plus on est sur un truc de culte
c'est un peu longtemps que
on va passer à deux sur cinq est-ce que
on peut rapidement regarder dans la
pièce s'il y a pas une petite capsule de
spolium qui travaille dans le
transformateur électrique non c'est vrai
qu'on aurait peut-être dû regarder un
petit peu parce que bon
pas très habile
de voir si il y a quelque chose de cassé
de un bouton pas bien donc lancé
donc tu ouvres le
jour où tu l'ouvres et en gros tu vois
que Ben en gros c'est des espèces de
gros fusibles des gros tubes en verre et
en fait on a trois qui ont été explosés
comme si quelqu'un allait tapé
latéralement oh flip
parce que là et tu vois sur l'intérieur
de la porte que il y a marqué laisse-moi
retrouver
il y a marqué
un numéro de casier
il est marqué fusible deux points et un
numéro de téléphone pour 125
ok bah alors peut-être qu'il y a des
fusibles de rechange dans ce casier
peut-être je tiens la torche
parce que vous souvenez avoir vu des
casiers sur la route
peut-être j'étais très
stockage peut-être qu'on peut y aller
peut-être chercher parce que là les
fusibles si on les change pas c'est mort
problème solution on y va allez au
stockage
pour voir des casiers tout le monde non
avant de partir tout le monde
32 je le passe sur 70 49 ou 46 ça dépend
tu vois qu'il y a coincé derrière la le
panneau électrique une sorte de petite
de petit papier plié
si il a écrit Gloria sur le papier
1752 je sais pas ce que c'est une année
une année un numéro technique c'est bien
mignon mais
celle de stockage du coup que vous
m'avez dit juste avant
vous entrez dans la salle de stockage
bon gros il y a plein de plein de
d'occasions
tu cherches le casier que tu as trouvé
bah oui c'était combien le numéro
dis-moi tu me l'as pas dit
126 125 je crois je pense
le casier il est fermé par un cadenas à
quatre chiffres
ans il y a plein de fusibles comme tu as
vu on a des dizaines très bien mais je
crois même solution j'en prends trois
j'en prends même j'en prends 6 parce que
je me dis peut-être ça peut servir
ailleurs dans la salle
je donne aussi fusibles avec la team que
tu prends si fusible ta mallette elle
est infini
quand même il y a d'autres et un Mac
ok bon vous vous faites autre chose dans
cette salle de stockage avant de partir
cherche du spa
valise mais plein
on la teste
sur la torche du coup si tu le mets pas
dedans et changer la batterie pour voir
combien est-ce qu'on peut les remettre
après bah oui je l'ai déjà fait il lui a
montré du coup il sait faire
il faut qu'on apprenne
démonstration clique
donc là il fait noir
batterie dedans un coulissant de manière
coulissante
et j'ai refermé le petit clapet voilà il
sait combien le petit truc tu vois
deux trois deux ok donc c'est pas bon
ok
c'est ce que je vais faire merci
ok c'est ce que vous faites
donc on a je vais changer il faut
changer il faut retourner je cherche
s'il y a pas une barre de fer ou un truc
comme ça quelque part qui pourrait
servir vraiment
est-ce qu'il y a une autre Lune Noire
est-ce qu'on peut chercher n'importe
quoi qui a l'air d'un objet contondant
on essaye d'ouvrir les casiers voir on
regardera rapidement un objet contondant
ou alors vous trouvez plusieurs choses
une corde voilà qui pourrait vous servir
et puis plein de barre
de stockage
donnez-moi je prends je prends ma
mallette je suis sportive
est-ce que je trouve une ceinture à
outils d'ailleurs
si vous passez Pierre-Alain la torche
contre les murs escale des
des dessins est-ce qu'il y a des
graffitis est-ce que
dans la salle vous voyez rien de spécial
peut-être changer fusible
on est en normal
vous allez changer les fusibles vous
retournez au panneau électrique
bon toi tu sais changer des fusibles
donc tu peux t'enlever trois fusibles
dans ta tête mais tu vas être pour et
donc
[Musique]
là sur le côté du coup tu as un espèce
de levier pour réactiver l'électricité
tu l'actives tu l'attrapes vas-y
ça ne fait rien bon problème ailleurs en
tout cas c'est pas le transfo il y a la
salle des machines qu'on a pas encore
fait
alors là ça peut être la turbine le
condenseur ou le séparateur ou alors la
pompe qui pompe elle vient de dire juste
tous les noms qui avaient sur la fiche
je vous propose aussi d'aller voir
générateur de ce cours
[Musique]
salle des machines vous entrez dans la
salle des machines elle n'a pas non plus
été vandalisée tout à l'heure d'aller
bien dedans et vous croisez enfin vous
trouvez ce qui a l'air d'être en
générateur un peu comme un gros groupe
électrogène en fait on va l'inspecter je
pense tout de suite en bon état mais il
faudrait le remplir pour le lancer le
remplir de quoi
donc peut-être un problème au niveau de
la pompe du séparateur ou du condenseur
ou de la turbine
alors moi je sais pas si vous aussi ça
vous fait pareil mais
on est dans une sacrée galère
il avait dit que le cœur du générateur
était derrière la double porte
électrogène donc c'est peut-être pas le
générateur
on peut peut-être remonter derrière la
double porte parce que vous en pensez on
prend chacun une barre de fer
ce gros groupe électrogène ici on verra
peut-être plus tard peut-être ça fera
est-ce qu'il y a des tuyaux qui partent
de ce groupe il y a des câbles qui
partent dans le sol tu as des bidons sur
le côté
un petit peu
d'exploser si on met des trucs dedans
vous avez une autre idée
comment ça marche un groupe électrogène
alors
c'est un peu compliqué je veux pas là on
a pas trop le temps
oui je pense en gros en générateur un
groupe électrogène un groupe électrogène
moi je préfère expliquer le générateur
grosso modo c'est la combustion c'est à
dire mais quelque chose à brûler soit
c'est de l'essence là on est en 1200 je
sais pas ce qui crame
s'entraîne voilà une turbine c'est comme
la machine à vapeur
et puis ça tourne quoi
je suis pas docteur à moi
ils sont vides les bidons non
j'attrape un bidon oui c'est de
l'essence c'est de l'essence d'une
licence de 200 ans plus tard
incroyable c'est ton essence églantine
attends je goûte alors
effectivement oui je vois bien les
arômes de hola oh
c'est bien raffiné ça c'est la signature
très bien là ça commence à faire un peu
mal dans le ventre j'aurais peut-être ah
oui j'ai des gargouilles
en fait le repas de Hugo
[Musique]
ça commence à digérer et ça commence à
pas bien digérer
est-ce qu'on peut remplir le générateur
avec ce qui va sortir de nous en tout
cas pour se manier parce que là c'est en
train de travailler là faut qu'on a
quand même l'avenir de l'humanité
vandalisée
peut s'en servir de toilette du coup
on peut se retenir deux secondes parce
que ce problème là
je comprends bien que je suis davantage
en
en maîtrise de la situation donc je
prends un peu le voilà en plus je la
torche donc est-ce qu'on peut mettre
tout de suite les bidons le les
contenant des bidons dans le générateur
on allume et on sauve le monde
c'est ça oui
il faut y aller je prends le bidon et
sous la direction de Pierrelaye monsieur
je remplis ça fait beaucoup de bruit et
ça rallume les lumières donc vous pouvez
éteindre votre torche c'est un succès
pour pour nous
activer un groupe électrogène
je prends ça comme un succès
personnellement
on n'a pas éclairé
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire ce que nous
a dit le monsieur mourant qu'on a qu'on
a dévoué nous a dit de faire ça et après
du coup on peut aller voir derrière la
double porte
vous allez à double porte il y a une
vous avez plus besoin de utiliser la
torche du coup donc l'énergie restera à
deux ah tout va bien
et il y a une espèce de de
lecteur pour badge donc vous passez
votre base je suppose
il vous accédez au cœur du générateur
qui est une espèce de grande cuve qui
descend dans le sol avec de nombreux
tuyaux et gros câble électrique
et de vous êtes un peu en hauteur sur
une espèce de plateforme en fer il y a
une échelle qui descend
mais l'échelle elle est coupée au milieu
et le reste de l'échelle du coup et par
terre et à côté d'un des grands tuyaux
il y a un cadavre
églantine vous avez rangé la corde tout
à l'heure la voici donc quelqu'un de
souple ah bon je suis souple
ça vous manquait de respect je suis
proche peut-être confier ça à quelqu'un
d'autre
quelqu'un d'autre qui descend
il faut toujours se poser les questions
avant de faire autre chose
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on voit dans
cette salle plus rien un peu autour de
toi
en gros la plateforme sur laquelle vous
êtes ça fait un espèce de U sur les
bords des murs et aux deux extrémités il
y a deux leviers
est-ce que ce serait pas la salle de la
porte rien à voir
peut-être qu'il y a un problème de pompe
que cette échelle descend dans la pompe
mais peut-être qu'on peut commencer par
les voir lui il y a deux choses à faire
il faut tester les leviers
aller quand même voir ce cadavre pour
voir s'il a pas un truc qui pourrait
nous être utile
une équipe cadavre une équipe levier
aussi levier gauche ou droite droite
gauche évidemment églantine est-ce que
vous vous sentez en même temps de
prendre la corde oui bien sûr je suis
d'accord je vous je vous sécurise je
reste oui merci
vous entendez un gros King dans les
espèces de grands tuyaux mais vous savez
pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé c'est
vrai que c'est pas comme ça qu'on teste
qu'est-ce qui fait quoi généralement
normalement on fait un levier là
j'explique comment on tremble chute
c'est quand on fait un levier d'abord on
regarde ce qui se passe et ensuite on
fait l'autre levier parce que là oui
c'est vrai on sait rien du tout en fait
bon bah d'accord
après c'est pas moi le concierge
vous êtes bien moi je suis en bas vous
êtes en bas quand ils ont activé les
leviers
de vin grâce au viewer oh merci les
vieux
je fais deux
désolé
donc tu descends en bas sans problème
donc tu vas voir le cadavre ou pas ou tu
entends le clown qu'est-ce que vous
voyez les gars
approchez-vous du cadavre si ça vous
embête pas trop je m'approche du cadavre
je regarde le cadavre comme ça est-ce
qu'il a un badge est-ce que sur le
ventre il a une grande cape avec une
lune noire dessinée sur le dos de sa
cape
et quand tu le retournes il est
complètement brûlé ah mais pas calciné
alors là va falloir je le lèche non
faudra aller chez le psy après
est-ce qu'il possède des objets sur lui
qui pourrait nous être utile alors déjà
je lui prends la cape
il faut qu'on passe pour des maisons
j'ai l'impression que c'est revenu à la
mode en 200200 voilà tu la mets ou tu la
prends juste je la prends jamais dans ma
mallette car je suis descendue avec ma
maladie
qu'est-ce que je fais d'autre je ne sais
pas je demande à Gloria en haut Gloria
oui que puis-je faire d'autre est-ce que
vous voyez autre chose au sol parce que
je vois autre chose aussi vous voyez un
je sais pas un tableau électrique on est
quoi on est dans une on est où on les
emplois déjà
c'était peut-être un peu dangereux de
d'actionner levier quand je passe à
l'école
ne restez pas là remonter c'est déjà
très bien
près de là où il y a le cadavre il y a
un des grands tubes avec et en fait sur
chaque tube tu veux me remarque qu'il y
a une porte
qui sont un peu opaque et sur chaque
tube il y a une porte avec
une route c'est pour ouvrir les portes
et du coup lui il est mort à côté dans
ses tubes
donc selon toute vraisemblance il a
essayé d'ouvrir et il s'est fait cramer
la face on m'a fait attention à vous
est-ce que je peux prendre la corde
l'attacher au volant de manière à
pouvoir être en haut quand on tournera
le truc pour l'ouvrir tu peux essayer si
vous voulez une truelle je peux vous
envoyer une truelle une truelle
vous allez pouvoir retirer un coup mais
pas faire des tours
avec la corde autour du moyeu de la
ronde tu vois et j'accroche le bout et
comme ça
je suis ok pour que tu fasses ça alors
je fais ça et en même temps je remonte
la corde pour
problème
[Rires]
du coup tu essaies d'ouvrir la porte
d'en haut en fait tu te rends compte
qu'elle n'était pas fermée par le truc
juste c'était juste poussé donc dès que
tu dis en fait elle s'ouvre est-ce
qu'elle fait un petit
et il ne se passe rien
on peut pas il y a du feu on peut pas le
voir j'ai appris ça il y a pas longtemps
ça fait un peu peur on dirait du lait
je vous raconte et il y a une barre de
fer en travers
peut-être
vous coupez pas les mains
oui non mais je peux essayer on apprend
tout toute façon vous savez quand on
fait une startup on fait un peu tous les
messages
si vous vous jetez contre la paroi de la
turbine est-ce que ça va pas faire
tomber la barre de fer tu peux y accéder
à la barre
voilà merci simple
quand tu la touche elle est un peu
chaude mais ça me brûle pas non plus
je la lècherai plus tard vous faites un
truc vous avec vos leviers pendant
qu'elle est dans la surprise maintenant
on sait jamais c'est un peu chaud
elle a enlevé la barre
est-ce que j'ai des leviers activés à
l'intérieur quelque chose
de de trappe fermée sous la turbine en
fait
alors là je vous raconte ça et vous me
dites quoi faire
la porte ou tu la laisses ouverte sur ma
mais je suis pas ingénieur
que tu es là
alors à ce moment-là je ferme la porte
ok bien comme il faut
aussi les bruitages et après je remonte
sans la corde juste comme ça en fait je
saute sur le mur et hop
et j'arrive en vous ok
il est bien mais bon ok tu remontes
très bien on a toujours cette histoire
de levier
cette fois-ci par contre procédure
normale où on fait un levier par un
levier quand même il est trop beau
qui est en premier
tu commences à entendre des bruits un
peu
comme si des machines reprenait et tu
vois que il y a de la vapeur qui remonte
dans les tubes
les années
et est-ce que
ça activer donc essayez ce que je
l'active vraiment c'est à l'heure de
marcher là toi de ton côté là
pareil même bruit la vapeur qui remonte
ok c'est nickel ça j'ai l'impression
qu'on progresse je fais un petit geste
de victoire comme ça pour motiver
donc là est-ce que Monsieur petit
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait là parce que moi
je je comprends pas exactement donc là
on a allumé le général on a allumé la le
générateur non le réparer le transfo
a priori on a remis en marche les
turbines donc là tout va bien si tout va
bien le générateur devrait fonctionner
mais si il y a un problème
au niveau du condenseur ou du séparateur
ou de la pompe donc là il faudrait déjà
qu'on s'assure que tout va bien est-ce
que ça marche est-ce que c'est diplôme
remettre en marche une usine moi j'étais
quand même voilà partis sur autre chose
parce que le générateur il
est-ce que il se remet en route ou
[Musique]
des turbines qui tournent il y a de la
vapeur qui en fait
la double porte qui vous a fait entrer
du coup c'était refermé derrière vous du
coup donc vous pouvez un nouveau budget
en fait au moment du budget vous vous
voyez en haut de la double porte une
espèce de petite fenêtre en vert vous
pouvez pas vraiment voir à travers parce
que c'est un peu en biais et vous
commencez à avoir des lumières rouges se
déplacer un peu aléatoirement dans la
pièce d'à côté alors je distribue les
barres de fer et qui veut la cape
oui je
moi je
joue mal à la comédie moi
s'il faut un petit alors du coup comment
comment oui c'est ça vous vous pouvez
rester planqué et si jamais c'est des
méchants c'est vous qui sortez et nous
on se cache est-ce qu'on peut faire la
course jusqu'à la fin pour voir ce qu'il
y a derrière
problème solution vous savez faire un
crocheter
sur combien d'extérité 40 92 75
se fiche pendant un moment au moment où
elle tombe et ça commence à se réavancer
vers vous oh vous avez l'impression que
ça avance vers vous c'est clairement des
personnes c'est des personnes et ça fait
un petit peu peur on je vote mais très
rapidement c'est pas je vote je dis on
se cache vous cachez-vous
vous êtes du coup sur le rebord parce
que est-ce que ce serait pas les
fameuses aigles rouges ah oui il y avait
l'air sympathique ma foi enfin en tout
cas
sur non plus mais bon qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire d'autre là dire à part
peut-être retourner
se cacher dans une salle de l'entrée
voilà vous êtes dans
le double revenus vers la double porte
mais du coup pour retourner dans le hall
faut la passer en fait à travers cette
double porte vous voyez des lumières
dans le hall d'accord vous êtes toujours
dans la cuve je pense qu'il faut qu'on
observe on ne sait pas qui sont ces gens
naturels
Monsieur Pierre Alain il a là il a la
tchatche oui d'accord enfin bon là vous
me demandez quand même beaucoup de
choses est-ce que je ressemble à un
minimum au la personne du cadavre on a
même pas son nom on sait rien du tout en
fait il y avait Adrien
il y avait Louise mais pas pas la
personne qui était non
c'est peut-être pas une bonne idée de
mettre la cape tout de suite
[Musique]
la discussion donc oui on était perdu
désolé
parce qu'après tout on est des héros
quand même on vient de remettre le
générateur
si on passe devant c'était perdu oui on
aurait mis le générateur il y a pas
moyen qu'on se cache du tout aucun
doute dans la galère
[Musique]
je garde quand même une barre de fer
dans la Manche comme ça
j'ai récupéré la corde avant de partir à
4 où est-ce qu'on vous sortez
et nous on regarde quand tu bats sur le
pont
le geste voilà bon courage mais
peut-être qu'à quatre on est plus
intimidant aussi oui donc peut-être on
sera quatre on voit ce qui
en a un qui reste derrière si c'est
celui qui meurt pas
vous voyez pas des gens qui sont en CAP
en enfance comment on dit
comme des militaires en fait hola
d'accord
qui ont derrière eux une sorte de perche
avec une sorte de torche de spolium
rouge
tête d'aigle niveau braktouf avec des
fusils que vous reconnaissez pas
spécialement mais ça a l'air d'être des
armes à feu d'accord et qui met en l'air
[Musique]
moi je lève les mec
vous êtes qui dans la Manche
on vient d'élixia
en pointant le cadavre de la femme qui
est au sol ah non non non
nous on est venu remettre le courant et
vous avez laissé faire ça du coup
c'était à nous c'est Gaston qui nous a
dit de venir il y avait déjà le cadavres
vous pouvez demander à
demander à qui
c'est lui qui nous envoie
écoutez monsieur nous sommes là on a
fait déjà un grand voyage on a un peu
fatigué
vous allez nous suivre mettez-vous au
sol les mains derrière la tête
[Musique]
j'espère que ça vous a plu
du coup
on a fini la petite session
d'aujourd'hui
on va on va partir sur une petite
demi-heure de discussion un peu de des
quelques aspects scientifiques qu'on a
pu effleurer pendant le pendant le jeu
de rôle donc déjà vous si vous avez des
trucs que vous voulez aller voir dites
moi j'aimerais bien que Valentine elle
me parle un peu plus du même de poche le
microscope électronique de Paul je pense
que spectateurs sont assez curieux
à regarder l'infiniment petit
à c'est un monde un peu utopiste tu vois
donc ils arrivent à miniaturiser plein
de trucs et tu l'as volé en 2023
il y a pas de souci
tout va bien
non mais je suis content de m'en être
sorti sur le fonctionnement du
générateurs
entreprise état collective la différence
c'est ça m'intéresse tu vois
un truc fondamental dans le dans le
délire
mais c'est agréable
donc du coup si vous voulez savoir
comment ça marche un générateur
géothermique parce que je me suis
renseigné vraiment
si vous reprenez le schéma en gros ça ça
chauffe de l'eau enfin ça prend de l'eau
chaude qui peut remonter c'est du coup
sous pression très profond dans la terre
et du coup on remontant la pression ça
me nuise du coup l'eau se dilate et par
un peu en vapeur et on eau chaude et
avec ça du coup soit on l'utilise
directement pour faire tourner du
turbine soit dans le cas d'une centrale
à cycle combiné si j'ai bien compris
désolé si je dis un peu des bêtises on
utilise la chaleur pour faire chauffer
un autre liquide qui part plus
facilement en vapeur donc il y a un taux
de d'ébullition plus bas que l'eau et du
coup ça fait ce liquide fait-on les
turbines OK et après l'énergie comme ça
et il faut de du pétrole pour ça non non
c'est parce qu'en fait il faut une pompe
pour pomper l'eau et donc en fait si le
générateur est en rade et que ça ça
tourne en circuit fermé bah faut bien un
moyen de juste l'amorcelant mais après
tu peux avoir des batteries quoi voilà
je veux dire c'est juste un choix vu en
fait il faut un moyen de pouvoir
relancer générateur en cas de panne qui
soit pas le générateur lui-même parce
que sinon ce n'est pas possible donc là
on a rallumé générateur de secours en
fait
et est-ce qu'on a des de la géothermie
en France d'ailleurs dans les en Alsace
il y a de la parce que là pour des
usages comme ça c'est on peut pas faire
ça n'importe où parce qu'il y a la
géothermie de haute énergie basse
énergie basse énergie vous pouvez en
avoir pour par exemple faire un
chauffage au sol donc en gros ça va
faire une surface de je sais pas 15
mètres carrés dans votre jardin où on va
enfouir des tuyaux à quelques mètres
sous terre c'est des endroits où la
croûte est plus fine donc c'est plus
chaud et en fait on va mettre de l'eau
l'eau va chauffer en souterrain et elle
remonte et ça fait un chauffage au sol
mais par contre pour des usages comme ça
il faut que ce soit vraiment des points
des points chauds pas au sens volcanique
mais des points où la croûte est plus
fine et en France je sais qu'il y en a
en Alsace des centrales comme ça où là
c'est ouais quelques kilomètres sous
terre
mais on peut arriver à voir des trucs
très très chaud quoi
[Musique]
ou un plus provençal ou en gros on va
c'est une entrée de VMC mais qui au lieu
d'être juste un trou dans le mur ça va
être un trou dans le jardin le tuyau va
passer à 1 mètre sous terre ce qui fait
que l'air qui va rentrer dans la maison
l'été il aura été rafraîchi à 13 degrés
et l'hiver il aura été très chauffé
voilà j'aimerais bien ça chez moi ouais
c'est crever de chaud non mais c'est
dans les nouvelles maisons
bioclimatiques et tout c'est très
utilisé dans le chat si jamais vous avez
des questions j'ai déjà tout ouvert du
coup s'il y a des questions sur quoi que
ce soit qu'on a abordé ou même d'autres
trucs en vrai n'hésitez pas on va
pouvoir y répondre
ouais si vous voulez
je reviens juste sur deux trois trucs
qui ont semblent un peu obvious mais on
sait jamais on va quand même les dire
les voyages dans le temps ça n'existe
pas vraiment peut-être un jour on sait
pas on va pas dire que ça existera
jamais mais pour les objets mais pas
pour les personnes
voilà donc ça c'est juste pour pour les
envoyer dans un monde un peu où il
n'auraient pas leurs connaissances
qu'ils ont dans le monde actuel et du
coup que je puisse reprendre un peu le
pouvoir sur eux sinon ça me posait
problème moi pour faire de l'écriture
c'est vrai qu'on a tellement de
connaissances que ça doit être terrible
et puis de Canadiens ou Provenceaux là
de connaissance et donc ça voilà et le
Spadium ça existe pas
peut-être que monsieur je n'ose pas il
finira par inventer spoiler mais
peut-être pas le plan tout de suite et
du coup les particules noires non plus
vous saurez plus en détail ce que c'est
cette particular dans les épisodes qui
suivent mais du coup c'est inspiré d'un
truc un peu réel et particules noires ou
on verra dans les épisodes qui
d'ailleurs enfin j'ai trouvé le concept
vraiment intéressant de du truc qui fait
que tu vois enfin tu vois pas après je
comprends pas comment ça pourrait
marcher bon on s'en foutu
une grosse merde je sais pas vous mentir
mais non c'est pas quelque chose qui
existe juste quelque chose de fictif qui
a pour but de créer un monde un peu
originel original qui tourne autour de
la science mais post-apocalyptique un
peu qui change de d'habitude
sont riches en lithium les fluides en
Alsace fluides du coup j'ai quelques
questions j'ai c'est quoi les agitateurs
de particules ah le truc dont je parlais
je pense ouais
tu as un espèce de boîtier en dessous et
tu as un bécher ou n'importe quoi que tu
mets au dessus et tu as un espèce de
comme un tic tac métallique je crois
enfin un tic-tac
oui voilà c'est aimanté et donc ça tu le
mets dans ton bécher avec ta solution et
en dessous tu as l'espèce de boîtier et
le boîtier fait tourner ton petit tic
tac et à ce moment-là ça mélange ta
solution
c'est il y a des chaînes qui font de la
chimie
[Musique]
je trouve ça assez intéressant de voir
justement ce qu'on peut faire enfin de
voir de la chimie être faite devant
devant soi parce que c'est vrai que moi
c'est un truc je m'en souviens d'en
faire en mais c'était catastrophique
quoi
c'est je regarde un souvenir un peu
ouais bizarre tu vois et du coup de voir
quand des gens savent ce qu'ils font
mais pourquoi ils le font et enfin là
c'est des trucs de création d'odeur
horrible
qui fait ça
c'est intéressant enfin je sais pas si
mais juste en regarder quelques-unes ça
permet de je trouve d'avoir une idée de
ce que c'est là en tout cas c'était une
bonne entrée en matière je trouvais
oh coucou Alice Vincent Amaury il y a
tout le monde
qui demande
Valentine pourquoi on l'a acheté
cailloux ah oui j'allais le dire
et du coup aller voir ma vidéo
approfondir sur ta chaîne au pire on
peut lécher les cailloux pour leur goût
parce qu'il y a certains minéraux qui
ont un goût salé pour la porosité parce
que s'ils sont poreux ils collent à la
langue et tu m'avais dit Clotilde que
vous faisiez pareil en archéo non ouais
des fois pour de la céramique on a
besoin déjà d'une cassure fraîche
parfois ça arrive que bah on casse
nous-mêmes un petit bout de céramique et
je sais oui qu'il y a des archéologues
qui parfois voilà pose le tesson sur la
langue parce que bah ça va te dire s'il
y a eu un engobe par exemple un vernis
donc s'il y a un vernis tu le dates plus
facilement enfin voilà ce genre de
choses
en le cassant non
non mais quand tu dis de la céramique tu
veux voir en fait la composition de la
terre les inclusions s'il y a du
dégraissant s'il y a voilà quel est le
c'est ça qui t'indique d'où vient
l'argile et donc d'où vient la poterie
en tout cas voilà elle a été faite voilà
que j'ai vu une autre petite question à
la con c'est elle finit ou la mallette
vous verrez dans le prochain épisode
mais vous en faites pas la mallette sera
toujours là un personnage
du sol aussi on
mange du sol
c'est pour alors on ne fait jamais ça
sur le sol de surface parce que c'est là
où il y a la matière organique c'est
dégueulasse mais on peut faire ça
possible ah oui alors déjà on fait pas
ça sur n'importe quel fin voilà s'il y a
une usine pétrochimique à côté on va pas
le faire mais sur certains sols une fois
qu'on les a un peu identifié on peut
faire ça pour vraiment analyser finement
les fractions en fait parce que en
sciences du sol on classe sable limon ou
argile en fonction de la taille des
particules et il se trouve que les
limons si on le fait glisser entre la
langue et le palais on peut le sentir
alors qu'avec les doigts on peut pas le
sentir donc voilà c'est toutes des
domaines vraiment particuliers
les trucs mais bon
je peux pas le dire
un truc qui me
un truc qui qui me semble intéressant et
qu'on va explorer j'imagine ça va être
le justement le statut est un peu
comment
enfin au niveau du podium comment il est
partagé comment il produit tout ce truc
là enfin je pense qu'on va on va arriver
un peu mis de côté parce que forcément
vous découvrirez un monde c'est
difficile de tout de suite rentrer dans
la sociologie instantanément non mais je
vois déjà que des éléments tu vois de
enfin
ça c'est toujours le truc qui avait des
fusibles à changer
mais sinon et je vois je vois le truc où
ça peut aller et c'est vrai que c'est il
y a plein de trucs à dire justement
quand il y a des ressources comme ça qui
sont centrales et ça a été vraiment très
vite évacué donc j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant oui dans mais maintenant
c'est tellement essentiel que du coup on
s'en fout genre suggéré
non ça marche si tu veux
en parlant d'évacuer il y a juste Léa
qui dit les problèmes gastriques
sur la tête et une bonne direction
vous êtes pas bien pas au max je pense
que là je veux dire avec l'adrénaline et
tout là tu tiens quand même tu oui là
c'est je veux dire ou alors ça part
direct
oui le café des sciences l'association
de vulgarisateur scientifique sur côté
de ouf
c'est pas moi j'ai rien dit
oui bien sûr il y a aussi ponction qui
est un collectif de streamer
de science ouais donc la vulgation
scientifique mais en stream
j'ai fait ça pardon fun fact qui n'a
rien à voir du coup j'étais dans un jury
de MT 180 donc ma thèse en 180 secondes
et à la fin j'ai fini donc chacun des
jurés disait un mot pour encourager tout
le monde et tout après qu'il soit passé
j'ai juste dit vous étiez tous
excellence sauf un et
ils l'ont tous pris super
malin
qui sont partis comme ça
c'est vraiment le contenu
à vous
[Musique]
quoi d'autre encore vous connaissez le
café des sciences en oui alors j'ai vu
un truc qui m'a beaucoup fait assez la
vieille dame s'apprécie mais elle doit
avoir des protections
[Rires]
c'est pas la bonne catégorie c'est
compliqué
du coup moi je me demandais pour le au
tout début on a parlé d'un papier que tu
as aidé à restaurer etc est-ce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose je me suis dit
s'il faut c'est impossible parce que
c'est possible de trouver vraiment des
papiers en état assez correct puisse
restaurer malgré les intempéries etc
avec le temps bah notamment oui les
papyrus mais parce que les papyrus c'est
l'Egypte et l'Égypte c'est un milieu sec
et donc ça conserve en fait
l'archéologie les vestiges qu'on
retrouve c'est en fonction de il y a
certaines zones sur terre qui sont plus
propices à trouver de l'archéologie et
notamment les déserts c'est parfait
c'est là où les choses se conservent il
faut du chaud du sec ou alors bah des
milieux remplis de flotte comme les
tourbières là tu retrouves
là où il y a pas de bah là il y a pas de
d'air il y a pas d'oxygène
et donc ça concerne les cheveux par
exemple ce genre de milieu parce que
l'humidité dans une tourbière ça risque
pas de de délaver complètement le texte
là c'est du papier donc pour le papier
oui c'est plutôt des milieux
secs ça dépend des trucs en fait tu as
des trucs si c'est dans l'eau ça se
conserve et ça ça pourrit ou enfin ce
que tu dis si c'est dans une tourbière
en fait
comment ça
il y a des endroits où on met des choses
les tourbières ça peut être des endroits
pour inhumer les gens montrer beaucoup
de momies on se trouve beaucoup de ou
alors c'est des c'est des lacs les lacs
qu'elle peint les lacs pas la physique
ce genre de choses ou tu retrouves
balade l'osier des paniers mais mais
c'est aussi des époques c'est à dire à
partir de quand on écrit aussi
l'écriture c'est fin sur papier c'est
papyrus c'est très récent en fait tu
vois c'est moins 3000 donc
finalement voilà après moi je suis pas
je suis pas du tout spécialiste de ces
vestiges là donc franchement j'ai jamais
vu faire de la restauration de de papier
simplement tu le vois dans les musées
quoi comment ils arrivent à rendre ça tu
vois bien dans les dans les dans les
tombes que les pigments résistent très
bien le bleu égyptien le lapis-lazuli ça
résiste très bien les encres ça résiste
assez bien
voilà et un truc qui est marrant c'est
que quand on fait des fouilles bon
maintenant beaucoup de choses sont
numérisées mais on a quand même gardé
cette tradition de tout
écrire sur papier et on écrit au crayon
de papier parce que le carbone c'est ce
qui résiste le mieux autant on a quand
même cette logique là d'essayer de
conserver les cris et c'est pas le stylo
bic c'est pas le stylo-plume c'est
et aussi c'est agréable il y a une école
un peu la comme ça mais ouais ouais on
fait nos relevés et tout qui en papier
et nos carnets notes sont au crayon de
papier c'est
le crayon papier ça veut se conserver
pendant le carbone c'est ce qui résiste
le mieux au temps
tu veux écrire tes mémoires tu te fais
aucun de papier je l'enterre dans mon
jardin
bonne boîte en plastique hermétique ok
du coup moi je t'ai filé un document que
j'ai
volontairement dégueulassé mais bon j'ai
pas beaucoup de capacités de graphiste
donc c'est un peu moche et en vérité il
y a un texte des prix
une session de test avec des amis du
coup pour voir si ça va rentrer dans les
temps etc le scénario et ils ont réussi
à déchiffrer une bonne partie du truc on
a même pas essayé
est-ce que c'est crédible comme tes
formations avec le temps ou vraiment pas
du tout aucun sens que ça se déforme
comme ça elle fait des gros yeux hein
non bah
[Musique]
non non
ça se passerait pas comme ça en fait les
dégradations ce serait pas temps sur
l'encre qui migre et qui coule ce serait
plus bah le le papier quoi qui est rongé
qui attaqué qui est
des fissures des
suivantes j'ai choisi le mauvais
je te crois quand même je suppose que tu
as un peu plus de basse que moi
en fait bah plus sur les tu vois les
tout ce qui est peinture rupestres et
tout donc des des écrits ou des
peintures sur des surfaces sur de la
pierre et compagnie en fait souvent ça
reste intact et dès que bah il y a des
visiteurs des cas de l'oxygène en fait
ça va pas migrer mais par contre il y a
des ce qu'on appelle la maladie blanche
des taches blanches qui vont arriver sur
les couleurs et qui vont venir
37 ans c'est en espèce de grosse tache
blanche
je sais plus ce que c'est faudrait
chercher faut que je cherche là j'ai eu
c'est plus mais ça s'appelle la maladie
blanche c'est le truc qui arrive dans
les grottes aussi
sur les fraises voilà c'est cette espèce
de employé je sais pas les fresques
rouges de Pompéi qui deviennent
blanchâtre c'est parce que il y a un je
sais plus ce que c'est un champignon ou
je pense que c'est un champignon faut
qu'on cherche
il commence à avoir des théories
nous donner pas trop d'indices on est
extrêmement intelligent
en équipe
tout seul à quatre on a bien un cerveau
4mmifères
moi je voulais revenir c'est bon la
ville d'horizon et le complexe Ikea ont
été complètement inventés pour le pour
ce drôle je crois que c'était en
Occitanie
est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait exister de
faire une ville pilote qui ne suivraient
pas les institutions
nationales des villes des villes un peu
particulières enfin qui sont créés de
toutes pièces dans un but précis il y en
a beaucoup c'est des capitales un peu
genre là c'est la capitale du coup c'est
un peu créé dans un but précis il y a
par exemple
Washington aux États-Unis qui a été créé
un moment en mode
chaque ville était trop comment dire
était trop connoté par machin donc on
s'est dit ok on va mettre un truc un peu
au milieu et puis comme ça c'est et donc
au début là j'ai regardé un truc à pas
longtemps et justement c'était juste la
première maison qui a été construit une
des premières maisons c'était a priori
la Maison Blanche et tous ces construire
il y a je crois au Brésil aussi où il y
a des bras comme ça
des trucs vraiment il y en a beaucoup
ils ont quoi pardon
je sais plus quel pays c'est mais où ils
ont fait une capitale comme ça et genre
ils ont fait des routes en mode deux
fois cette voix personne qui habite là
c'est Marianne marche hein
la capitale administrative mais ouais il
y a plein de comment c'est avant ça
s'appelait comment ce pays
Ellie tu le sais ils y sont allés dans
Top Gear
baume-là c'est que tu as plein de enfin
dans le tout le truc de l'urbanisme en
fait beaucoup d'échecs aussi de de trucs
bah là on est en train d'en voir un je
pense
en temps réel avec le truc qui est en
Arabie
ou c'est des trucs
qui ont déjà été testés des trucs sur
des lignes sur des trucs bien
particuliers mais qui pensent d'abord
sur des concepts qui sont très
centrées sur une idée très forte et en
fait c'est pas comme ça que les gens
vivent c'est pas comme ça que les
activités enfin
si par exemple tu veux construire un
truc tout droit la pression va être
tellement forte pour habiter juste à
côté enfin tu vois la ligne le point le
plus proche de du centre du centre bah
il est juste là et puis elle est où la
centralité dans cette ligne là enfin sur
toutes les villes comme ça il y a des
gros problèmes de
de penser d'en haut et en fait les
villes c'est des trucs qui sont
relativement organiques et qui répondent
à des pressions un petit peu quasiment
organique quoi ou c'est parce qu'en fait
c'est ça c'est une cumulation de besoin
organique parce que on est humain et du
coup tu as des besoins qui sont
temporels et
et d'humanité enfin de relation et du
coup ça ça match pas forcément avec des
quadrillages un petit peu vu de haut en
mode théorie des besoins des humains et
c'est un peu tout le truc justement avec
avec la planification quoi c'est à quel
à quel point est-ce qu'on peut planifier
la vie des gens et à quel point est-ce
que bah tu as besoin en fait que les
gens vivent de la manière dont ils
vivent et puis après toi tu essayes de
d'organiser ça d'une manière comme tu
peux quoi enfin oui
les quartiers autour des gares par
exemple qui voulaient des quartiers
d'affaires des quartiers où tu vas d'un
point A un point B le plus vite possible
et en fait c'est des quartiers qui sont
glauques maintenant parce que parce que
bah oui l'humain
a besoin finalement de centre de
centre-ville mais niveau médiéval quoi
un truc c'est plutôt un déplacerons
auxquels on circule en fait vraiment ce
côté de circuler avec des et souvent les
voilà les artères très droites et tout
après ça fonctionne quand même enfin
c'est ça qui est toujours particulier
aussi c'est tu vois tu as des modèles
comme on le voit dans pas mal de villes
américaines mais même européenne mais
c'est la séparation à ce point-là des
quartiers des trucs là ça ça fonctionne
quand même jusqu'à une certaine limite
quoi c'est que pour plein de gens c'est
très efficace d'aller tous les matins à
un endroit de revenir à un endroit enfin
de séparer les activités c'est juste que
a priori peu importe enfin ça dépend sur
quel paramètre tu bases le succès ou le
le non succès tu vois ça peut être
relativement efficace économiquement ou
sur les pas enfin ça dépend vraiment les
paramètres que tu que tu donnes par
exemple tu peux très bien avoir un
quartier enfin si tu divises les
populations tu vois tu as toutes les
personnes qui vivent dans des villes
dortoir les personnes qui vivent dans
des villes d'affaires et ça te permet de
pas payer d'impôts là où tu travailles
mais enfin tu as moyen de jouer un peu
les impositions tu as moyen de jouer les
investissements et de vivre dans un
endroit qui protège toi ta population et
les gens comme toi et d'aller travailler
dans un autre endroit sans que sans que
ça se touche quoi donc il y a pas mal de
choses comme ça quand même qu'on voit
avec des
techniques de ségragas de ségrégation
qui ont une forme d'efficacité en fait
mais c'est pas forcément ce que tu veux
pour le bien commun mais bon c'est pas
on n'est pas toujours la recherche du
bien commun et de l'optimisation de ça
quoi
voilà donc
c'est intéressant
mais on va voir justement comment
j'ai oublié
justement on va voir comment
quels sont les groupes sociaux qu'on va
trouver dans comment ils s'organise quel
est l'efficacité de toute la production
de
apparemment pas ouf
vraiment très exceptionnel de parce que
une expérience va se passer extrêmement
mal qui risque de faire exploser à
minimale le complexe mais dans ce cas là
tu prévois enfin je veux dire oui bien
sûr je me dis dans un environnement
post-apocalyptique ou les gens sont
juste mal organisés et du coup
l'organisation est pas top quoi
forcément dans chacun se débrouille un
peu avec ce qui les moyens du bord
forcément bon bah
la moindre personne qui puisse aider les
gens avec des Caps quoi ça c'est
toujours
plus tard pourquoi
parce qu'ils veulent
tous les super héros n'ont pas de
attention
dangereux d'avoir une carte
écoutez vous voulez revenir encore sur
un dernier point ou en clôture ce
premier épisode
je trouve intéressant
le jeu pierre pape feuille ciseau ça
remonte à Caen
ok bah du coup moi j'ai une petite
suggestion de régie qui est quand même
pas mal c'est vrai que j'ai pas du tout
pensé mais vu qu'on a quand même des
joueurs débutants autour de la table
est-ce que
votre premier jeu de rôle ou un de vos
premiers jeux de rôle ça vous a fait
plaisir
je vois un peu à toi
tu en as pensé quoi un peu tu es super
très cool
ouais moi j'ai saisi la liberté enfin
petit à petit je me suis ah mais on a le
droit d'y aller d'accord ok et ça m'a
mis un certain ça m'a mis deux heures je
pense
que c'était vraiment
enfin moi j'en ai je suis débutant aussi
j'en ai fait qu'un mais
ouais j'ai trouvé que ça se présentait
direct ça rentrait dans le roleplay
direct c'était cool quoi bah j'espère
que l'audience en tout cas et puis
apprécié parcourir ces tunnel glauque
moi je pensais pas que ça allait être
aussi hein
je me suis dit il faut que j'ai
un sécateur
l'objet le plus
utile en aventure
c'est pas tous les petits euh les petits
bâtons et les petites ficelles tu les as
aussi ou quoi
maintenant on a un cruciforme de toute
façon
quadrillage quoi donc mais c'est pas
c'est pas que des bouts de bois ça clou
officiel
mais après on sait que c'est toi
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là n'hésitez
pas à aller checker les réseaux d'un peu
tout le monde autour de la table donc on
rappelle un peu tout le monde sur
Youtube en finale ça voulait voir les
chaînes il y a des commandes dans le
chat pour l'exclamation soit le nom des
Perses je suis séance de comptoir
Valentine ou j'ai oublié le nom de ton
perso églantine pour aller voir séance
de comptoir du coup point d'exclamation
ou Pierre Alain c'est ça pour moi c'est
passé sauvage ou Clotilde ou Gloria
voilà et moi c'est frérot ou
Frédéric ou Gauthier où j'ai au spoil il
y en a en plus il triche et non non il y
en a on en a chacun 5-6 parce que j'ai
pris les orthographes vous pouvez faire
des fautes ça devrait placer vous
débrouiller genre
il n'y a pas de des opportunités et pour
Guillaume c'est MJ the Willow oui alors
bon moi
[Musique]
il y a pas de fautes à faire là c'est la
lettre M la lettre J et oui non moi je
fais pas de science par contre désolé
hein je joue un peu de jeux vidéo sur
twitch là
non mais oui
je joue et venir poser des questions sur
le jeu de rôle c'est avec grand plaisir
qui répondrait donc n'hésitez pas à
balancer tout le scénario
mais on peut parler si vous avez des
idées à me donner n'hésitez pas parce
que ça peut être cool j'avais vraiment
vous avez des bonnes idées vous me
donnez je veux dire ah peut-être pour
pourquoi pas l'intégrer etc mais voilà
bon voilà donc n'hésitez pas à passer
voir les réseaux sociaux d'un peu tout
le monde on remercie encore une fois de
le CNC de nous aider à financer le
projet le quai des savoirs de nous
prêter le studio qui est quand même
vraiment très très stylé les équipes du
quai qui nous filent un coup de main
notamment marié
est-ce que la Maison Blanche est bien la
première maison construite à Washington
quand a été inventé le pierre feuille
papier ciseaux toutes ces réponses vous
les aurez dans un prochain live tu sais
vers quand tu vas le faire ce live non
bah la semaine prochaine
lors de des gens milieu de semaine début
de semaine allez je dirais peut-être le
week-end prochain ok donc dans une
semaine voilà dans une semaine vous
aurez la VOD sur YouTube dans 7 jours
tout pile vendredi soir la ved sur
Youtube et sur les plateformes de
podcast
donc podcast la VOD YouTube elle sera
sous-titrée
et puis voilà merci à notre mg oui merci
merci
la régie et oui
on serait dans le noir
je pense le live sur la régie donc merci
à eux merci Nico
bientôt sur YouTube sur la plateforme
n'hésitez pas à suivre aussi les comptes
de RUL of Science
donc tweet Tik Tok insta Twitter parce
que là vous allez avoir plein de clips
jusque jusqu'à la prochaine émission en
fait vous allez avoir des clips des
doucements voilà des des résumés sur
Twitter possible des photos voilà j'aime
bien quand elle est juste posée sur le
la table des petits trucs comme ça donc
n'hésitez pas à ton animal et du coup on
se revoit dans deux semaines c'est ça
c'est ça ça va être vrai que tu as pas
mis de commande
en mode bam directement tiens on va
réfléchir aux personnages davantage on
va leur donner un peu de profondeur de
la texture bah là c'était l'occasion de
les appréhender
d'apprendre à connaître
donc normalement je ne parle pas de
couches
s'il vous plaît
merci merci
on se retrouve dans deux semaines du
coup
passe une bonne soirée bon week-end et
puis à la prochaine ciao à bientôt Ciao